this video is sponsored by Royal match
and let me tell you matching tiles has
never been more fun or satisfying I mean
who doesn't want to help out Old King
robbert rebuild and restore his castle
to its former glory after being
destroyed in the mighty Battle of 1284
I'm just kidding about that last part
but you do restore the King's Castle and
feel like royalty doing it Royal match
is a completely free-to-play Match 3
puzzle game that features no ads let me
say that again in case you didn't hear
me it has no ads you can just relax and
switch off the day and play to your
heart's content through all 7,000 of its
levels and special events that are
constantly popping up or turn up the
heat if you want to compete with your
friends scores and honestly I've been
curious about this game for forever
since I've seen it like everywhere and I
am so glad that I finally downloaded it
and gave it a chance so if you want to
play a very oddly satisfying game while
feeling like royalty and without any ads
click the link in my description to
download the game for free today and now
on to the
video so recently I've uploaded a lot of
my thoughts on tears of the Kingdom in
different incremental videos which was
kind of dumb of me but it's just that
there always people who would watch
those and then leave a comment and I'd
want to respond to that comment so I'd
film another one and then upload that
and then there would be more comments
for me to respond to and the cycle just
you know kept going but on the flip side
there are tons of people that watched
one or two but not all of them which is
kind of a bummer because a lot of my
videos I made in response to said people
so because I'm obviously incredibly
intelligent I have compiled them all
into one massive tears of the Kingdom
thought video who knows maybe the longer
format will actually Reach people on the
platform that or maybe I'll have to SA
rice another cororo to the algorithm to
appease it once more eh what's another
cororo am I right either way in this
video you'll find my original Zelda rant
my much longer Zelda rant as well as my
rebuttal to one of the most popular
arguments against the story in Zelda
games and 20 of my ideas and how to just
fix all of this for everybody across the
board located at the very end so sit
back relax fall asleep if you feel like
it and enjoy 2 and 1/2 hours of my
thoughts on Zelda tears of the kingdom
and I hope you're okay with my voice
because there's a lot of it in this
video hello my friends on the Internet
it's me Bandit I hope you've all been
having a great summer actually it is not
summer anymore it's very much so not
summer anymore it's literally Halloween
day while I'm recording this so I have
no idea why I said summer so let me do
that again I hope you've all been having
a great
fall and I hope that you've been playing
a lot of video games and having a lot of
fun playing said video games I um am
sure you've noticed that things on the
channel have been a little different
recently and by different I mean
nothing's been happening ever since
tears of the Kingdom released my uploads
kind of went that's like a car like just
hit the brakes you know like it's just
kind of stopped or slowed down
exponentially and there are a couple
reasons for that and I just kind of
wanted to level with you all say hello
show my face let you all know that I'm
still alive barely I'm sure you can tell
I've got the sniffles cuz it's been
dipping in the temperature outside but
you know besides my red nose and
terrible appearance um I just wanted you
to know that I am alive and otherwise
healthy and I hope the same for all of
you but there are some things that I
need to level with you about and I think
it's only fair to level with you about
these things because it's going to be
affecting the content on the channel
going forward because yes the channel is
going forward contrary to what some of
you no doubt were thinking uh but it's
going to be it's it's going to be a
little bit of a little bit of change so
first things first I'm just going to
come out and say it although before I
say it I do want to preface everything
that I say about whatever games I talk
about in this video I want to specify
and reiterate iterate and reiterate that
anything that I say in this video is
just my opinion and you would do well to
remember that uh and you would do well
to remember that everybody has opinions
and some opinions are stinkier than
others sure but that doesn't make them
any less L of a valid opinion right
unless of course you're of the opinion
that like 2 plus 2 equal
3 but that's not an opinion that's just
a that's just factually wrong anyway you
get what I'm saying if I say something
in this video about games tears of the
Kingdom about games that you don't agree
with just let it be all right it's my
opinion is what it is it's going to hit
everybody differently so here we
go when tears of the Kingdom released
I think that a lot of the people in the
Zelda fandom were excited obviously for
a couple different reasons one it was a
brand new Zelda game coming out well I
say brand new right but of course it was
still in the same world as as breath of
the wild was set in but it was a brand
new experience from the ground
up with an asterisk beside that because
again it was the same link and controls
and world as breath of the wild but
anyway you know what I mean you get what
I'm saying it was an it was a very
exciting new experience and one of the
other reasons why people were so excited
for people like myself and people like
undoubtedly you watching this video and
you who watch my channel uh it was
exciting because of the lore
possibilities that came with the game
cuz see breath of the wild was in
a breath of the wild was vague right I
think that's kind of an understatement
breath of the Wild's entire world has
references to like all of the others Eld
games out there there there's no
shortage I mean you you can literally
find the ruins of lawn laon Ranch you
know from ocarine of time and you can
find an entire like intact mostly intact
uh uh Shrine of whatever it's called
from Skyward Sword I'm sorry I I haven't
been researching recently my terminology
is kind of gone right now uh listen if
you don't if you don't keep studying
something sometimes you lose some terms
all right but you know what I'm talking
about breath of the wild introduced new
lore to the
series but in a way that was still
Loosely connected to everything and it
was very interesting and it worked for
breath of the wild and it gave rise to
Zelda theories like we had never seen
them before because people have always
theorized about the Legend of Zelda hell
that's why Nintendo went ahead and made
the timeline Canon back in you know the
2000s because the fans of the Zelda
franchise love to theorize and connect
pieces between game and whatnot and you
know what it's fun because we fans of
the series like that sort of thing you
know not all fans do but a lot of fans
do all right and when breath of the wild
came out it
was it was strangely new but also the
same but there were certain things that
were just missing but because breath of
the wild was the only game in this new
lore Continuum if you will it worked we
could talk talk about where's the
Triforce we could talk about where's
Ganondorf we could talk about you know
things like that because it was just
breath of the wild and theories were
very very fun and because of that we
knew that when breath of the wild was
getting a sequel a direct sequel oh boy
that must mean all sorts of stuff for
the theories and the lore of breath of
the wild we were finally going to get
answers about a lot of the the things
that I just mentioned you know Ganondorf
the Triforce and speaking of Ganondorf
they announced before tears of the
Kingdom even came out that he was going
to be the main villain so there were so
many reasons to be excited for tears of
the kingdom and the story that it was
going to bring to us now I'm not going
to go into all of it because well one I
don't want to piss everybody off uh
because you're Pro you were probably
expecting me to absolutely love tears of
the kingdom and I think I think if you
were to ask me that question the answer
is not very it's not very simple it's
complicated do I like tears of the
kingdom yes I think it's a fantastic
experience I think that the best way you
could experience tears of the Kingdom
from a gameplay perspective would be to
experience it without having played
breath of the wild beforehand because
90% of the game is still just walking
around the same world of Hyrule there
should have been so many more sky
islands they should have done so much
more with the depths but again I'm not
doing a full-on like review video where
I just bash the things that I don't like
about tears of the Kingdom uh because
there was too like uh the crafting
system obviously and I'm talking about
The zonai Crafting system crafting your
gizmos and gadgets and flying machines
and weapons and whatever and the fuse
system was really cool um but gameplay
aside did I like tears of the
Kingdom honestly no and and and to and a
lot of that is on me because as not just
a fan of the series but as a a
Creator specifically a Zelda theorist um
i w i I talked about all sorts of what
if scenarios uh for tears of the kingdom
and the thing is it's fun to talk about
those sorts of things but you got to be
careful right because you got to be able
to temper your
expectations and so to me man the things
that I focused on and was expecting to
hear about one of the the one of the
biggest things of which was like the
force was just was it wasn't even hinted
at in tears of the Kingdom like it it
was just and there are a lot more uh
topics than just the Triforce but I'm
just using that as an example of how the
lore and and story of Tears of the
Kingdom just did not care at all about
anything that I wanted it to care about
instead it spent the time uh building up
again new lore like the birth of hyru
was birthed by the zonai type new lore
and this this is just another Ganondorf
and another imprisoning war and another
set of sages and another all powerful
set of relics called the zonai stones or
the zonai secret stones and and the
master sword can now break because of
the superpower that Ganondorf has from
one of these new relics and then the
master sword needs one of these new
relics to repair itself to be able to
beat this other New Relic and where what
where's the Triforce again you know what
what Triforce what golden goddesses what
what what are you talking about uh who
cares about that it's all about the
zonai you see what I mean like there was
there was nothing in tears of the
Kingdom that I wanted there to be and
there was everything that I didn't
really care about and uh it's almost
like Nintendo was watching
YouTube like developing tears of the
kingdom and they watched our videos and
Nintendo black crisis's videos and
zeltic videos and monster mes videos and
highroll Gamers and like everybody's
videos about the zonai excuse me and
they were like you know what that's good
that's really good why don't we just do
everything in the sequel about them and
like anything that could possibly be a
question of anything just it was the
zonai the whole time does it have to
connect anything in the series no it can
just be completely new okay see see now
I'm ranting and I don't want to rant
about tues of the Kingdom because like I
said I don't want to tick anybody off
but I just I need to let you know how I
feel about the game so that I can tell
you what's going to happen to the
channel because of this
now where the hell was I oh yeah and
then like randomly the director of
breath of the wild enters of the Kingdom
fuju Bashi comes out in an interview and
says oh it could you know the birth of
hyru could have been a new Continuum or
not a new Continuum but another like
hyru could have been destroyed again in
the past and then like it was built
again in the past and like the passage
of tens of thousands of years doesn't
matter and hundreds of like here's the
thing okay here's the thing about tears
of the Kingdom lore and what it proved
about the era of the wild of Zelda game
so breath of the wild and tears of the
kingdom and I guess age of Calamity but
it's not canon so who cares uh but what
it proved about them and also a little
bit about the rest of the series is
that the lore of the series doesn't
really matter it really needs to just
be I hesitate to say this because it's
not true
but it kind of
is but it's almost like the lore of
Zelda games need to just be handled game
to
game I mean and I say that's not true
because Zelda games reference other
Zelda games within the Zelda games but
when every game comes out and especially
the previous two and
just doesn't care about any of the
previous Zelda games and just introduces
new
stuff and to be honest with you it's not
altogether all that interesting
anymore that entire that very concept
right there affects people like me
people who who try to generate
interesting topics and theories to talk
about see I haven't been just sitting on
my ass this entire time since tears of
the Kingdom came out and not well I have
been but what I mean is I haven't been
theoretically sitting on my ass and not
coming up with video ideas I have video
ideas this isn't a video that's that's
crying to people to give me video ideas
I there are so many it's it's an it's an
entire world okay there are so many
things to talk about in tears of the
Kingdom what's this person's story
what's that person story you know
whatever and we could explain lore all
day long but here's the
thing it's not that interesting anymore
it worked in breath of the wild because
things were just vague enough and it was
just breath of the wild so we could
still kind of Wiggle around and make
things connect and talk about what ifs
but now that tears of the Kingdom has
come out and it's like we still don't
know what the hell the dragons are we
still don't like we we still don't know
where the golden goddesses are we still
don't know if this is the same high we
don't even know if this is the same
Hyrule that has been traversed in the
rest of the series or if it's like the
new Hyrule from the adult timeline or
like and we don't know what the hell
happened to the Triforce is it within
Zelda it how how is it within Zelda I
mean clearly we're just writing new
rules for stuff in tears of the Kingdom
like there's there's just zonai secret
Stones now and they can bust things up
like The Master Sword and the master
sword used to be more powerful than the
Triforce by the way cuz Ganondorf had
the Triforce of power Infuse him
literally return him from the dead in in
Twilight Princess and the master sword
was the only thing that could actually
permanently kill a Triforce empowered
individual like the master sword is all
powerful Darkness cannot even be near
the blade and then like a new little
teardrop Stone empowers a dude gives him
gloom and Gloom just snaps the freaking
sword like it's a little toothpick you
know so like we're clearly we're just
writing new mythology for the Legend of
Zelda that overrides everything that
we've known so far and to me because
you've got to remember I'm a fan first
before I'm a Creator the the only reason
why I was a Creator about the Legend of
Zelda specifically and to the extent
that I have been on my channel is
because it's been my favorite franchise
and why is it my favorite franchise
because it's the most interesting it's
always been the most interesting to me
it's the most heartfelt it's got the
music it's got the the the stories it's
got the lore and it's got the themes
that are the same across the games and
it's always just been so cool to me I
remember when I was a kid and you know
the first time that I played Wind Waker
and the intro segment like described the
events of ocarine of time I was a kid
and I saw that and that was amazing to
me I was like wow it's like a Contin and
that was the same Ganondorf and then it
was so much deeper now and like you
needed multiple games to kind of
understand his entire
story that is is cool to me and again
that's not cool to everybody but it's
cool to people like me it's interesting
to people like
me and that's my problem with tears of
the kingdom and honestly with breath of
the wild too but more so tears of the
Kingdom it's like none of that stuff
matters anymore a new Zelda game can
come out and it can just write new rules
like
in in in the next game who knows it
might just be
like there might not even be a spirit of
the hero anymore or or you know you know
what mean do you understand what I'm
saying I don't even know if I'm coming
across intellectually at this point I
just kind of turned turned the camera on
I didn't really know what this video was
going to be and I'm just talking I'm
just talking about how I feel about
tears of the kingdom and I didn't even
it's it's been my camera's been rolling
I probably cut this video down by the
time you're watching it but my camera's
been rolling for well over 15 minutes
and I did not mean to make this video
that long so I'm going to stop there but
just to summarize I don't know if I said
it or not but just to summarize what I'm
trying to
say tears of the Kingdom story is not
that interesting to
me there I said it so what is that going
to do to the channel that is the reason
why I'm making this video it's going
to basically I'm not I'm I'm really not
going to do videos on tears of the
Kingdom anymore and it's I think that's
a big disappointment for me because you
know for years ever since tears of the
kingdom was uh uh teased back in 2019 as
breath of the wild 2 you know the sequel
to breath of the wild I mean like
everybody and their mom was looking
forward to that right and and we were
all looking forward to it for many
reasons many purposes like I was looking
forward to having years worth of content
to talk about uh because of Tears of the
kingdom and then it released and I was
just like wow nothing really matters
anymore and then they went and said that
there will be no DLC additions for tears
of the kingdom and that was like the
nail in the coffin to
me so I I covered the game with my boss
lore video because I yeah I did another
one that was just focused on
Ganondorf um in tears of the kingdom and
I think I think that's about it I don't
know if I'm going to do my dungeon lore
video for tears of the Kingdom because
again none of it really
matters it's all just new stuff I mean
there was so much in tears of the
Kingdom that they could have capitalized
on could you
imagine if the lightning dungeon or
whatever the hell it's called the one in
the gudo desert could you imagine if
that was the resurrected Arbiters
grounds I mean that's what everybody was
expecting but no you know it had to be
some new some new ancient zonai ruins
thing everything is zai everything is
zonai and man there were there were
certain things and tears of the Kingdom
again I I don't know what reminded me of
this I think my brain was just going
through the dungeon and I remembered the
cut scenes at the end of The Dungeons
and so now I just I just got to mention
it tears of the
Kingdom like how could Nintendo release
a product that has like those copy and
paste cinematics in it you know what I'm
talking about whenever you finish a
dungeon and your helper you know be it
reu or TAA T's kid I forget what his
name is or or yibo or or whoever you
know or
siden it when you finish the dungeon you
are met with like the spirit of the
ancient sage and they say the same damn
thing that every other one says and your
partner character says the same damn
thing Demon King secret Stone secret
Stone Demon King Demon King secret Stone
and and it's it's the same it's the same
copy and paste cinematic like there's no
character development there's no anyway
anyway I got to stop I got to stop see
cuz I'm not I'm not trying to make this
one of those videos I'm just doing this
so that I can explain to you what's
happening anyway I've been rambling for
long enough so like I said I'm really
not going to be making videos based on
tears of the Kingdom anymore does this
mean I'm going to be not covering the
Zelda franchise uh no not at all of
course I'm going to cover the Zelda
franchise I mean like it's the Zelda
franch this was not enough to shake the
Zelda franchise from being my favorite
franchise although it comes close
because there are other really really
good franchises that I enjoy which leads
me to my next point because I'm not
going to be drawing from tears of the
Kingdom really I mean it may come up in
videos obviously because it is a Zelda
game but because I'm not going to be
drawing from it for like my main source
of videos I'm I know I've talked about
it for years now at this point but I
like it's time to Branch out for the
channel like it's it's officially it is
time so if there there is one thing that
I would ask from you guys if you're
still watching this hi to those of you
who are still watching this if you if
you're still watching this just comment
hello I am still watching this down
below you know just do that but anyway
if you're still watching this after you
leave that comment either edit that
comment or put another comment um about
what your favorite franchise is besides
the Legend of Zelda not even a video
idea I just want to know like what you
guys's favorite franchises are um I we
talk about what mine are but that
doesn't really matter uh but yeah just
let me
know and yeah that's about it that's
about all I had to say oh before I let
you guys go since you're all still
watching clearly and you've all just
left those comments saying hello I'm
still watching this um you should go to
a link to success excuse me a linkto
success.com why because that's my book
yeah in the in the meantime I've been
helping um Athena hotus which is a
phenomenal
entrepreneur uh friend of mine that I
was blessed to have met via her reaching
out to me in email um but I've been
helping uh her a little bit with some
contributions uh in a book that she has
written she's the author but I'm I wrote
the forward and several parts of each of
the chapters um things like that anyway
it's called a link to success it is a
Zelda book but it's a book about finding
success out of our love for the Zelda
franchise so I greatly I highly
recommend you heading over to the
website and just checking it out and if
you do decide to pre-order it um I
believe we are going to be meeting up
and signing uh the pre-ordered copies
physical copies of course it is also up
for digital but you know I can't really
sign a digital copy but if you want a
signed copy of that book from the author
and
myself hop on that pre-order
but anyway that's about all I had I just
wanted to bring you guys up to speed
with where I was because you know things
on the channel have been very quiet um
and I wanted to temper your expectations
for what is to come which is like I said
videos about the Legacy Zelda games you
know I still have the dungeon lore and
the boss lore videos to complete for the
other games in the series um but I'm
also going to be branching out that that
video series to other franchises and
just covering other franchises in
general all right sound good
team I wouldn't blame your being a
content creator as a big element to your
gripes with heres of the Kingdom too
much because a lot of us feel the same
way in fact it's really refreshing to
hear you have these conflicting feelings
about the game because I've been curious
for a while now how the content creators
feel about it I would still love to hear
more of your thoughts in a more focused
video you are definitely not alone
Bandit I would gladly welcome a complete
outpouring of your honest thoughts and
conclusions you just R I feel like I was
the only person who
was
an hour video would be
amazing all right fine but for a warning
I do get a little rambly when talking
about exactly how I feel about games
particularly Zelda games so what I'm
going to do is I'm just going to play a
little bit of the Beloved game that
we're talking about while I'm telling
you exactly how I
feel and we'll see how this goes I'm
just going to keep the camera rolling so
if you had seen my video that I had
released a little little bit ago called
the Zelda rant um then you probably
already know my feelings about the game
at least my feelings in general but in
case you haven't allow me to Briefly
summarize I think that it's a very fun
game to play gameplay-wise running
around killing enemies you know it's fun
in the same ways that breath of the wild
was fun uh partially actually mostly
because it's the same freaking world and
engine and enemies and setup and goals
and pretty much everything from breath
of the Wild and that was already a fun
formula so this game is fun in the same
ways just you know with the added uh new
Ultra hand and things like that um but
it is a bit lacking and by a bit lacking
I
mean quite a bit lacking in certain
other ways some ways that a lot of
people fault me for because you know I'm
just being a crying baby nerd with a lot
of expectations which is fair which is
fair but other ways which are rather
fair I feel across the board ways like
this right here now I'm going to I I'm
actually going to start this video off
by talking about the positive things
believe it or not but this is still in
my intro segment so I'm going to get
this one out for free okay for those of
you who have played breath of the wild
you'll probably recognize pretty much
everywhere or at least 90% of what
you're going to be exploring in tears of
the Kingdom because 90% of it is going
to still be in the very familiar world
of Hyrule the surface whatever you want
to call it in tears of the Kingdom and
as you'll probably remember places like
this are where Cass is for instance
standing here and
being well-being cast and having like a
unique quest line for you I forget what
it is in breath of the wild when he's
standing here but it's like a hero's
treasure thing he's got a song anyway
clearly this entire area right here was
built around that now in tears of the
Kingdom this is a recycled area Cass is
no longer here in fact Cass is who knows
where Cass is but Cass is no longer here
and all we really get for treading old
ground is a
cororo anyway but that was just for free
all right that was for free just because
I happened to log into my game standing
here I'm actually going to start out
talking about all of the positive things
about the game of which there are many
and I have a little outline over here to
at least keep myself at least somewhat
aligned with what I'm trying to say so
starting out with the good things how it
felt to play in the sky that's what I
have written down number
one this right here just this this this
is what feels like a new game this is
what feels like tears of the kingdom and
this is what is a ridiculous amount of
fun oops I'm about to fall off while I'm
talking here every island that you see
off in the
distance there's no secret sauce for
there's no there's no like you see all
those islands all the way off over there
or maybe that one or maybe there's of
course I don't think there's anything
above my head as far as another island
is concerned right now but that one like
right way over there like how how am I
supposed to get over to that Island
right you might ask yourself there is no
secret sauce you just learn the game and
the mechanics that the game has brought
to the table and you figure it out for
yourself you use your new abilities to
build ridiculous vehicles or whatever
and and make it there on your own and
that is phenomenal it took the
exploration of breath of the Wild
Whoopsie I don't know if I've gotten
this cororo here have I gotten this oh I
have okay it took the exploration of
breath of the Wild and just multiplied
it by having you not have ground in
between where you're trying to get
because on the surface of Hyrule as
complicated as it gets is just trying to
climb up like a mountain or something
and not having enough stamina or maybe
it starts raining and then you fall down
you can't get to where you were trying
to go that's as complex as it gets for
exploration down in the world of Hyrule
in this game there's nothing connecting
us not only do I have to figure out
probably where to how to climb up that
Island when I get there or you know
whatever but I've got to figure out how
to get over there
first and that's brilliant tears of the
Kingdom's
concept is a phenomenal one as far as
just a damn fun toplay game is concerned
and of course one of the biggest changes
if not the biggest change to tears of
the Kingdom from breath of the wild
would be the addition of ultrahand and
the removal of all of the other
abilities that we had in breath of the
wild I don't think I have to waste video
time explaining to you why ultrahand is
so fun to use all the reasons that
you're thinking of in your head all the
things you've created the Unholy
aberration the Unholy Creations that you
people watching have created in this
game with ultra hand and the Unholy
Creations that I've created are all
worth it what more is there to be said
about ultrahand and the other thing that
was a a positive and a negative for this
game but we'll get into that later but
the other thing that I really liked
about this game was the the combat and
by the combat which was exactly the same
as breath of the Wild
I mean the weapons all the different
kinds of arrows have evaporated Into
Thin Air and now what you do is you fuse
them with whatever you would like to
shoot and if you want an elemental arrow
that means you fuse them with an
elemental piece of equipment or gear or
whatever and that's cool because now you
can do a lot more with that now you can
have weapons that have base uh uh Buffs
like for instance a Zora spear will
always have the buff called water
Warrior which means that if it gets
wet you see now you see how it's at 66
damage there with its infusion now if it
gets wet it is at 132 and that's really
cool the ability to just I mean their
ridiculous appearances aside like you
know this freaking fire heart on the end
of a really crappy looking sword their
ridiculous appearances aside it's a
really cool concept I like the ability
to craft my own weapons that's the end
of the good things that I wrote down so
and I have here written down anything
else question mark before I get into my
complaints about the
game there were a couple pieces of new
music a few some of which are even
memorable so that's cool the kg theme's
pretty
cool obviously the story continuing from
breath of the wild and giving us new
interactions with the characters that we
grew to love from breath of the wild
like sidon and
reu uh and unibo those are really cool I
liked that I liked some of the story
additions I'm really thinking you guys
I'm really thinking I'm trying I'm
trying oh of course the the new areas
right so it is cool to
have I get sad every time I see just how
much empty space there is up here but
anyway I get you know it is really cool
to have new places to go even though it
is largely 90% the same world it's it's
cool to have new places to go and even
though the depths is the same in every
corner if you've been to the depths here
you've been to the depths here if you've
been to the depths here you've been to
the depths here if you've been to the
depths here you've been to the deps here
you get my point but it is cool to have
just a lot more space to just run around
if if any if nothing else right so
that's very cool but before I actually
go into my harsher criticisms about it
let's let's just talk about the other
powers that we've got real quick so fuse
was always an odd addition to me because
fuse is essentially just ultrahand it's
the same concept they just they just
dedicated it to its own power for some
reason because see ultrahand already
sticks things together in infinitely
right and fuse sticks things together
infuses them into the same item or
weapon or whatever it seems to me that
that should have just been a feature of
ultra hand like fuse should have just
been like a subfeature of ultra hand
like I don't see why you know this
option that you get with fuse right here
could not also pop up if you're
targeting it with ultr hand it's not
like it's taking up different buttons
with those two Powers just being
extremely similar I almost feel like
they ran out of ideas for powers to give
link and autobuild is just ultr hand
that saves you time but again it almost
seems like that should have just been a
subcategory of ultrahand I I think that
they should have had bombs make a return
as an ability both square and circle I
mean that would have taken up this slot
and that slot right there because Square
bombs were like the greatest invention
in breath of the wild that they they
were okay bombs that would sit where you
put them I mean mind-blowing right I
think that was one of the most
mind-blowing things about breath of the
wild actually now if you want to blow
something up up you've got to have bomb
flowers that's pretty much it either
that or you've got to make some sort of
chemical reaction that I can't think of
off the top of my head and I know a lot
of people are going to talk about the
time bombs because these are technically
The Replacements to the bombs but look
at how large and unwieldy these things
are you know who the these are not the
these are not fair Replacements to the
bombs that we had and we also can't make
them explode on command anymore they
have to be
timed like that it doesn't matter if I
shoot it again it's going to blow up
when it's going to blow
up so the removal of the bombs from
breath of the wild is a very strange
feeling but I I honestly I think they
might have removed them because clearly
they had a focus on removing all of the
you know like glitches and things that
people would exploit about the breath of
the wild engine like for instance
whistle running which you cannot do
anymore people would exploit that in
breath of the wild the bomb jumping
people would exploit that in breath of
the wild so I think that I think that
they removed those probably directly to
combat those exploits for movement that
people would uh I mean everybody used
them I used them but anyway I will
summarize this little bonus segment of
talking about Link's abilities by saying
I like this one I really like this one I
surprisingly really really like this one
these two should have been part of this
and we should have had our bombs back on
honly like energy based bombs that you
can decide when they blow up one of
which is a a cube should be a staple of
the Zelda series and that is a hill that
I will die on they should reappear in
the next game and that is a hill that I
will die
on okay with all of that aside as the
Sun is
setting thematically it is also setting
on the positive things about the game
and you might be wondering Bandit you
were being positive this whole time yes
yes I
was so let's get into it speaking of the
sky islands which we are standing on we
are standing on PR perhaps the most
unique one of them all you remember how
just a few minutes ago I pulled up this
map and I I took a look at it and I was
like oh wow look at all that empty space
yeah yeah look at all that empty
space when when I first started playing
this game I was oh boy I was oh boy I
was excited I mean everybody was right
and this is where you start spoiler
alert sorry if you didn't know that I
don't know why you're still watching
this if you didn't know that but this is
where you start and it kind of teaches
you how to play the game the same as the
great plateau in breath of the wild and
then you make your first descent down to
Hyrule and you you excuse me you ascend
your first Sky View Tower you go up in
the sky and you get your first piece of
the map and it's
empty it's all empty except for that
Island you were already on but you think
to yourself okay that's fine there are
other places in the sky that are going
to be much more cluttered I'm sure much
more densely packed with with sky
islands and content in the air I'm sure
and little by little every time that you
go up a tower or at least this was my
experience every time you see something
like
this just two or
three and that's it and your your your
heart begins to sink little by little
and not only are there
really not that many sky islands in the
game where there should have been like
it should have been mostly new sky
islands in tears of the Kingdom because
that's what really feels like a new game
and that's what's really fun not only
are there pra like basically not any but
a lot of them are just copy and paste
This Island right here this little
quadrant thing with the little
quadrants okay that's one of the only
unique ones there because it also has a
temple to deal with oh look there's the
quadrants oh look there's a
quadrant oh look there's a piece of the
quadrant oh look there's another
quadrant oh wow look is that is that
what is that a quadrant another quadrant
wow oh look there's more quadrants like
in every single corner of the map there
are copy and paste islands and there are
copy and paste like platform Islands
there are even a couple copy and paste
Globes oh and even the the
flying the flying labyrinths they
literally just took and and I don't know
if you can see like like just blink back
and forth but these flying labyrinths
which are just flying for no freaking
reason and which are just they they are
duplicates like literally you pull up
this Labyrinth object file in something
like blender 3D and just contrl C and
control D I'm sorry I forget how to
duplicate in blender it's been a couple
years now but you just duplicate the
entire model and put it in the sky and
that's what they did with these and
there and then they were like you know
what that's cool that's content this is
content this is content that people are
are asking for in tears of the Kingdom
absolutely and there are a few unique
islands in the sky there's the great Sky
Island there's the two temples there are
the two temples up here and their
Associated
Islands there
are the bre the bravery and courage and
you know those islands where you you
fall down even though they're all really
similar to each other with the whoopsie
with the same Concepts um but there are
those and then of course there is the
Thunderhead Isles which again leads to a
temple so there are the three Temple
leading is Islands the great Sky Island
the quadrants the Spheres the copypaste
labyrinths and the falling
islands and honestly I think I've just
summed up oh and the copy paste platform
summed up all there is
new in the sky now I'm I'm not trying to
like stomp my feet on the ground and
bang my fists on on the desk and just be
an absolute child about things and just
complain because I wanted more blah blah
blah but I I am going to do that a
little bit actually because listen this
was a $70 game okay this this was a $70
this was a new experience that was being
sold to us you want to know what they
did in their last $70 game or $60 game
or whatever all of
that all of that okay and you cannot
tell me that they ran out of ideas for
Sky
Islands when they created all of this do
you do you want like just recall with me
back in breath of the wild or even this
game if you want how every single like
in this segment right here there are
probably like five secrets in this
segment right here there's probably 12
in this entire quadrant of the map
there's
probably 100 200 that's probably not
even scratching the surface I don't know
how I died there but anyway that's
probably not even scratching the surface
the creativity that we were expected
that that we had gotten used to from
breath of the wild was astounding
staggering I mean it won game of the
year easily because it was
so big and complex and and intricately
deep detailed and then in tears of the
Kingdom like I keep mentioning the
actual new content that everybody was
excited for was that we were going to
the
sky nobody really cared about re like
yes we were okay with revisiting the
same world of Hyrule sure because it's a
big wide openen world and a lot of us
felt like they could have done a lot
more with it because really the whole
world of H hyru and breath of the wild
was sparsely populated but only with
like one of two things a Shrine or a
cororo seed basically basically there
were a few other things but basically
that was the overwhelming like that was
their content that they filled the place
up with and so we were we were okay with
a return to Hyrule given that it would
bring more to the table more unique
bosses around the place more unique
items around the place the return of
dungeons maybe there were several
different reasons why we were excited to
return to Hyrule but one of the biggest
things was that we were excited to go to
the
sky and this is what we
got I don't know how to like I'm not
going to sit here and calculate but I
would be willing to bet just looking at
this and looking at this that the total
surface area of
new actual new content in tear of the
Kingdom actual new land surface area
content would be probably less than
10% probably just just just eyeballing
this right here probably an absolute
maximum of 10% of the the land volume
that we were used to in breath of the
wild and I know what you're thinking but
bandit look at that that's an entire
other map underneath Hyrule and it's
just as big as
Hyrule well like I was saying earlier in
the
video I I admire Nintendo for keeping
the depths a secret for as long as as
they did like I really really admire
Nintendo for for like nobody thought
even a little bit that there was going
to be another entire world down down
down
under and they hit it they HIIT it
really well and boom everybody was Subs
uh subscribed wow everybody should be
subscribed watching this but no
everybody was surprised when this
happened and and when we first would
fall down in the chasms and fought giant
frog monsters and whatever like that's a
beautiful thing I'm not going to lie the
depths they could have done so much more
with so much more and I'm going to go
into this a little bit more a little bit
just just here in a second but excuse me
there aren't even tough enemies down
here like there at the end of the game
you're still going to be running into
like red boblins down here truly
ultimately even though we have these sky
islands and the depths 90% of the game
still takes place right here in the same
hru and like I was just saying we were
okay with
that we were excited about that even
because there were a lot of new things
that they could have done with this
Hyrule but here's what they did the
towers are back just different in
roughly the same locations but not quite
shrines are back in fact there are more
of them to do and cororo seeds are back
in fact there are more of them to
do literally quite literally the same
stuff from breath of the
wild they just brought back just a
little bit differently of course the
shrines are I'll be honest
I they had some really fun puzzles in
shrines and breath of the wild and they
have really fun puzzles and shrines in
tears of the kingdom and if I were
to if I were to say which ones I
preferred I'd probably say the ones in
tears of the Kingdom because tears of
the Kingdom's sandbox with ultra hand is
a lot more open you can just you know
you you can it's it's truly open you can
combine anything to anything and really
exploit the physics system um so I I
liked the shrines in this game as far as
shrines are concerned but I would have
traded half of these shrines for I don't
know anything else one of the other
things they did do is they added a whole
bunch of
caves but 90% of the same of of the area
that you'll be traversing in this game
is the same hyru and 90% of what you're
going to be doing in the same Hyrule is
the same stuff going to a tower solving
a shrine so that was also kind of a let
down oh you know not to kind of
flip-flop back and forth but one of the
other things that I forgot to mention
that was a positive about this game
would be some of the new enemies that
they brought into it I really liked and
notice I said some because they aren't
all new enemies most the vast majority
of the enemies are still the copypaste
enemies from breath of the wild but the
Phantom
ganons hello those are cool as hell I
like I really really really enjoy uh
fighting those those scary hands the
froes were a welcome addition and the
glys of course were a welcome addition
in fact you know what speaking of gly
I'm just going to go over there and kill
the one that's on the bridge why not but
I've got pretty much nothing bad to say
about any of the added enemies um the
bosses
that were new for the dungeons I like
them about as much as I liked the I mean
I liked that they were at least their
own species and their own
monsters um but I mean I I lik them
about as much as you would like you know
the the different blight ganons from
breath of the wild which by the way used
to are are also Phantom ganons and I
know that I previously was praising the
combat kind of for giving you a lot more
customizability I mean look at this I
have a flower Shield like you guys I
have a freaking I have a flower Shield
do you have a flower Shield I didn't
think so unless you do but mine's cooler
obviously because it's my flower shield
and I love my flower Shield I wouldn't
trade my flower shield for the world of
course I can't do stuff like this with
my flower Shield oh I can I actually had
no idea that I could Shield surf with my
flower Shield because typically you
can't when you fuse something on there
but either way I like my flower Shield
it's cool the ability to fuse things is
cool but here's the other aspect to that
you know how in breath of the wild
everybody was complaining about oh
weapons breaking like everybody was
complaining about weapons breaking even
people who defended that mechanic
admitted that it was kind of a you know
oh why is my thing blinking stop telling
me where or deposits
are yeah turn off but like I was saying
even people who defended this mechanic
still
thought you know I just realized that
I'm trying to multitask this and I'm
probably going to suck at
multitasking but here you guys are going
to see the the greatest way to kill a
gly and you're going to be so
[Music]
impressed seriously though why are you
so mad what did I ever do to
you I sometimes try to see if I can hit
two of head in one go but that never
really works out for me where you going
here take one of these with you oh
you're too far up oh what's he doing
what are you
doing oh oh that's big I forgot how big
that is it's been it's been a while
since I've killed one of
these oh I'm sorry did you die I didn't
notice you were still
alive but anyway it didn't happen in
this fight I was kind of hoping that it
would happen just so I I could complain
about it a little bit but when when your
weapons cuz okay so here's the thing a
lot of people were hopeful that with the
addition of Fusion on your weapons and
the ability to do stuff like this
destroy your fuse material a lot of
people were hopeful that you could
repair your weapons and keep your
weapons and stop them from from breaking
so often and having to say goodbye to
your good weapons and therefore promote
you know a healthier use of your weapons
rather than trying to only use your
weakest ones pretty much all the time
and trying to save your your big ones
pretty much all the time and never
really using them but that's not the
case your weapons will still break all
the same in tear of the Kingdom it's
just that not only is your weapon still
breaking you also fused something to it
and here's why that kind of
sucks because not only are you breaking
one weapon now you're breaking one
weapon and one material and a lot of
these materal materials you also need
for your gear upgrades so you're having
to spend not just weapons now but you're
basically it's a double whammy now with
weapons so not only do you yes you do
get to craft custom weapons and that's
really cool but the toll is much higher
now because now you're burning through
your materials and weapons like I'd be
okay if if when you fuse it the material
on the end would break and you could you
could keep the base
weapon that would make a lot more sense
to me but that's just not the case
everything breaks and the master sword
being able to like fuse whatever on it
and like it it looks really cool with
the runes but you know kind of
transforming into and taking the
characteristics of whatever you fused
onto it is is a strange touch but it's
pretty cool though it makes sense
because in that way like if I were to
have fused you know a blunt like a mace
thing onto the master sword not only
does he swing it like a mace instead of
like a blade but it can also mine much
easier etc etc so the fusion system for
weapons is a good thing and a bad thing
like I was saying oh yeah and the like
like like the return of the like likes
was pretty cool too I'm not going to lie
but again if you've been in one cave
you've been in them all so it's kind of
they kind of did the same thing that
they did with all of the world and level
design and breath of the wild in uh with
caves and tears of the Kingdom that is
to say is that warm enough okay cool
that's warm enough that is to say they
brought a New Concept in the cave
which is cool it's a cool Concept in and
of itself can I go down here yes I can
it's a cool Concept in and of itself but
they didn't do that much with it if
you've been in one cave really you've
been in them all now the depths on the
other hand like I said this was a very
very welcome addition to the formula of
breath of the wild that nobody was
complaining about and I'm I'm I'm like
90% sure that they were inspired by uh
Elden ring ring uh because if you'll
recall one of the delays was announced
shortly after Elden ring came out and
Elden ring has this phenomenal moment in
it I don't know if any of youall have
played it but if you've been on my
channel for long you know that I am a
huge fan of Elden ring will be covering
it when the DLC uh drops um I've covered
it before on the channel um but Elden
ring is a beautiful beautiful game that
I
have like nothing bad to say about
really and it has a beautiful moment in
it where you go down this this elevator
in a well and you're like o what little
Chasm or or catacombs is this going to
lead to and it just keeps going down and
keeps going down and then everything in
front of you opens up and you see a new
Starry Sky which is really like just the
roof of the ca of the caverns but it
looks like stars cuz it's all sparkly
and it's it's a whole other world down
there a whole other world and it just
opens up and then like that the text on
the screen pops up you know and it's
like uh cofra River or or I forget
you know what what the area is called
but anyway it's a beautiful moment and
I'm pretty sure that Nintendo was
inspired by that with the concept of the
depths now again just like I said with
the wells The Depths Were A New Concept
that they brought up but didn't do all
that much
with and just like the wells if you've
been in one part of the depths you've
been in all of them because there's
always a mine nearby that has zonite and
there are always zonite ore deposits
around that have some really really
really ridiculously weak enemies
guarding it and that's about it I mean
there are a few Unique Kind of quests to
do down here don't get me wrong the
design of the depths is cool but one of
the things that they did decide to do
with the depths that I am cross with
them about and will likely not forgive
pretty much
ever would be in every single mine
there's a chest and inside this chest is
either 100 zonai charges which you will
use to upgrade your zonai batteries or
get
this a DLC or amiibo item from breath of
the
wild just stuck in a chest down here
fans of breath of the wild who picked
this game up which is the vast majority
of people I mean that's why this game
sold 10 million copies in the first 3
days just an insane insane turnout is
because everybody from from breath of
the wild was really waiting and nipping
at the butt to play this game when
that's the only reward for traversing
every corner of the deep deep dark
depths the only reward that you get is a
chest that
has the tunic of the sky in it or
whatever or the Majora's Mask in it like
that's a cool little Easter egg same as
it was in breath of the wild sure cool
to wear around and kind of show off sure
but there's no it doesn't inspire a
drive in you to go and figure out what's
in each chest it's the same stuff from
breath of the wild and and speaking of
the same stuff carried over from breath
of the wild practically everything is
now they did give us from here downwards
some new gear
but again that stops right here and it
goes right back to all of the same gear
from breath of the
wild and then of course the ancient
Hero's aspect I read a lot of comments
online asking people why they're upset
that a lot of the armor sets and music
and enemies and gear and and weapons are
reappearing from breath of the wild they
get upset and they say it's a sequel
what did you expect when have you ever
seen a sequel to debut with 90% the same
gear but I'm I'm going to I'm going to
stop talking about I'm going to stop
talking about gameplay stuff now because
that's going to be that's debatable I
mean all of this is debatable this is
all just my opinion and OB it's I can't
believe I've been recording for nearly
an hour now and it's taken me this long
to say hey this is just my opinion
really honestly I shouldn't have to say
that but you know it's the way the
internet is these days a lot of people a
lot of you watching will respect this as
my opinion as you should and you know
even if you disagree but there are some
of you watching this right now who are
just very very very upset that my
opinion differs from yours and all I'm
saying is just just understand that if
you disagree and you feel differently
and you loved everything that I said
that I didn't love or will be saying
that I didn't love that's fine I'm
telling you right now that's fine you
can still be my friend and I can still
be
yours take this thumbs up as proof of
that of my friendship because this isn't
something that fandoms should divide
over I'm just but I'm just letting you
know how I feel because I also have read
a lot of comments saying that the
internet is a very lonely place if you
don't find people who agree with you and
honestly I agree so that's why I'm doing
this for you guys to find solace in my
opinion and for me to find Solace for my
opinion in you guys so really honestly
I'm I'm done talking about gameplay
right now because what's more important
than the new the amount of Sky Islands
the shape of the sky islands the the oh
yeah this was a cool addition man I I
wish they had done more with like giving
link powers in this game because this
was actually really really cool being
able to do what shica or I'm sorry yiga
people do but anyway what's more
important than any of this to me is the
story and damn it that's what they let
me down with the most in this game so
let me start out by saying that tears of
the Kingdom started off extremely strong
strongly started off with a
bang this cut scene right here was
everything it was perfect what that
finding Ganondorf everything was so
mysterious but he's going to say
something here in just a second that I'm
going to really zero in on and I want
you guys to pay attention to because it
was
so just chef's kiss and it could have
been so much more than it ended up
being so this right here is the first
thing that was extremely intriguing to
me the fact that something could shatter
the master
sword this blade can stand up against
the Triforce by the way can kill a
Triforce blessed
individual in Twilight Princess it's
shown to be able to do that my power
cannot save you from me and that's the
thing like I
agree so what's his power right what's
this new grand power you who carries
that fragile sword
this is what I was talking about this is
what I was talking about can I pause
this no I can't fa okay so I'm just
going to back out of this
because it goes on for quite a while
longer but that right there when
Ganondorf says Zelda and you who carries
that sword are
link listen none of us knew that this
was going to be a closed time Loop Story
by the time when we were just playing
this okay we so when Ganondorf looked at
zeld and Link and recognized them you
know how insanely cool that felt because
For the First Time it felt like he
recognized them because it was the same
Ganondorf from earlier in the franchise
for those of you who are new to the
franchise from breath of the wild
Ganondorf has been a big baddy since the
days of Ocarina time technically
technically since A Link to the Past
because that's when we had figured out
that Ganon used to be a a man known as
Ganondorf dragmire if you were to have
read the A Link to the Past manual that
came with the game and then in Aina of
time in 1998 1998 the big bad dude
actually Came Out Swinging and man he he
has left a lasting impact on the gaming
world ever since his first appearance
Wind Waker came out and his appearance
just got cooler it was the same
Ganondorf but we're fighting him Untold
years later the original World of hyru
has been swallowed underneath the waves
and he's back he's going to resurrect
the old world because he always wanted
it for his people you know so his story
got deep we love Ganondorf then he died
at the end of that game and in the end
of that timeline and in the child
timeline of course he had an appearance
in Twilight Princess a little bit less
to say about him in that game but still
a cool
appearance and then we said goodbye to
him for 17 years and now he's back and
he's been slumbering and creating
ganons this whole time right so a lot of
us were thinking oh this is this is him
from the Fallen timeline he's been here
the whole time he recognizes Link and
Zelda from Ocarina of
Time or from a link to the past or or
from you know A Link Between Worlds or
or whatever like he he recognizes them
oh my goodness or or you
know it felt so cool to have Ganondorf
of all people directly talk about the
timeline in a Zelda
game but of course we know that that
wasn't the case he only knew who Zelda
was because Zelda got sent back back in
time removed from the situation
immediately exactly like breath of the
wild and he knew Link's name because
rahu practically whispered it in his ear
before he sealed him away for countless
Millennia or however long it was excuse
me which is significantly significantly
significantly less impactful and
speaking of ganondorf's
impact there wasn't any I was just
talking about how deep of a character
Ganondorf has been this whole time and
some of y'all might not have even known
that some of you might have thought that
Ganondorf was just a stereotypical video
game baddy this whole time but for a lot
of people you know or at least the ones
who who like to read in between the
lines and whatever Ganondorf is is
deeper than just that and really
honestly we have his Wind Waker
appearance to thank for that we also
have his aine of time appearance because
the first time he saw link he was
impressed by him being courageous and he
spared the little Link's life and then
he grew to regret it of course 7 years
later when link grew up and kicked his
ass so like Ganondorf has always been
like
you you you can see him respect other
people you can see him have human
thoughts you can see him have human
nobility like in Wind Waker he's a cool
villain people love him so to bring him
back and also I'm not talking about the
four Swords Adventures Ganondorf because
I mean let's face it for Swords
Adventures lore is kind of weird but
anyway to bring him back but it's a new
Ganondorf and then to give him
absolutely no background or no backstory
at all like literally the the first time
we see him is right
here after the start of the game of
course but this is this is all the
backstory we have he's already mad he
already wants to take over Hyrule but
you might be want you might be thinking
to yourself oh that's exactly what he's
done in the previous games right not
necessarily he wanted the Triforce in
the previous games he wanted the
ultimate power in the previous games he
wanted the wish in the previous games in
this game he just wants to take over
Hyrule just because happens to see this
zonai secret Stone on ru's wrist just
because it's he has one moment of
feigning depth to his character and it's
at the very end where he says I must
like something like I Must Destroy all
my enemies that is what a king must do
that's as deep as it gets with this
Ganondorf to say that that was a let
down to say that it was a Monumental
letdown to me
would be a massive
understatement because he was one of the
biggest pools for the game when they
revealed that he was going to be in this
game and he had this new design that was
just so Kick-Ass looking I mean oh my
God right but it's just nothing it's
just a big old nothing burger and we can
come up that's the thing about like
talking about the lore of this game is
we can come up with whatever Back
stories we want to as fans but it's all
so
equally it's all just fanfiction at this
point like the difference between
fanfiction and a and a theory in my
opinion is that a theory should be at
least marginally more believable a
theory should be actually you could see
that functioning that way a fanfiction
is just writing whatever the heck you
want just writing whatever story you
want and you know it doesn't necessarily
have to fit with anything and I need to
move on from Ganondorf because I if I
keep talking about the let down and what
they could have done with Ganondorf will
be here for forever and I've already
talked a a long time and I still have
quite a bit to get through another
problem that I had with the story of
this game was the fact that it did not
really follow up on its continuity from
breath of the wild so the biggest and
I'm just going to hit I'm I'm just going
to come Out Swinging with this
point the one of the biggest things
right differences between this game and
breath of the wild is the lack of all
the shik
technology that's not the same Tower
from breath of the wild the towers from
breath of the wild the guardians from
breath of the wild the shica Slate from
breath of the wild is just gone just
gone and we had a lot of theories as to
why that happened but recently Fuji
bayashi the director of both breath of
the wild and teers of the Kingdom came
out in in an interview and really the
interview is not new but it was just
released to the public uh recently um
and I say recently it was probably like
a month or two ago at this point but in
that interview he says and you probably
already know what I'm about to say say
in that interview he
says that the shik technology just up
and disappeared and nobody knows
why I don't even know how to go into
that to be honest with you I like I
don't even know how to go into why that
is the most uh like I apologize but I
don't apologize why that is the most
asinine explanation of all time like
what the the shik technology just knew
after the Calamity Was Defeated that its
purpose was done fulfilled and so it
just decided okay that's it that's it
I'm going on vacation I've done my duty
so I was just in a uh podcast with uh
ratat toar and my and monster maze who
I'm a pretty good friend with and uh you
should go check that out because if
you're if you're down for complaining
about tears of the Kingdom there's a lot
more in that podcast but but in that
podcast we talked about this and monster
maze brought up the point that if the
shik technology was just waiting for
Calamity Ganon to be defeated so its
purpose could be fulfilled then why
didn't it do why did it not do that with
the original Calamity Ganon that the
shika technology was built for 10,000
years
ago you see what I'm saying why now it's
almost because they they just Nintendo
just knew kind of what they wanted to do
but they didn't know how to connect it
to breath of the wild so they didn't
they just didn't and I mean I could go
into a lot more but it it it just comes
down to a whole bunch of things from
breath of the wild just not fitting very
well like people don't act like they
were just under the actual threat of
Extinction like what four or 5 years ago
or however long it's been in between
both games they act like they don't even
know that that happened like do you not
see the world still in Ruins do you not
know how that happened do you not want
to ask how that happened like what what
is going on and then there are people
who just don't remember link and I get
it some people like random NPCs if they
don't remember link really it's whatever
but I'm talking about the people that
are a bit more important to the story
I'm talking about people like
hesu you know hu he's the big cororo
dancer dude how many times does link go
to talk to hu in breath of the Wild a
lot or all of the cororo for that matter
how many how many interactions does link
have canonically with cororo and breath
of the wild a lot he even canonically
goes and gets the master sword because
he starts tear of the Kingdom off with
the master sword so
canonically as of the cannon events of
this very game he has entered the Lost
Woods and he has met the cororo and the
deut tree and he has obtained the master
sword so why do they act like they're
meeting him for the first time in this
game game the first cororo that you go
talk to is like what you can see
me bro I just found 900 of you people I
drew this sword I I come to the Lost
Woods every Tuesday for for for brisket
Tuesdays all right we we share
meat it's a meat Fest like what what do
you mean you don't remember me do you
see what I mean that just doesn't make
sense it doesn't fit and everybody had a
whole bunch of expectations for for
tears of the Kingdom's new story we were
all a bit tired like it worked for
breath of the wild the way that the
story was all in the past we didn't
really accomplish much in the present
game all we really did was figure out
what had happened in the past oh come on
link you can do it get up the hill but
that's all that's but that worked for
breath of the wild but in tears of the
Kingdom we were all ready for something
new we were ready for something that was
going to
be eye opening and something that we
were going to be able to play through
rather than just kind of figure out that
happened in the past but they did the
exact same thing in this game that they
didn't breath of the wild Zelda gets
removed from the scene immediately goes
in the past and lives that whole time
until the present creating all of the
different teardrops around the place and
creating the story that we once again
have to piece together because we don't
get to play through
it it's a tired formula but one that
they copy and pasted because they could
not deviate from the concept of breath
of the wild that was a nonlinear story
they wanted to accomplish another
nonlinear story that you could just do
in whatever order you wanted so to do
that once again they sacrificed a story
that you actually play through with your
own two hands and just like my ancient
breath of the wild review that I don't
even know if it's still on the channel
but just like that one I I questioned
whether it was worth it for the sake of
good storytelling also anybody who's
watching this you better not dare
question my my building prowess this is
the greatest vehicle you've ever seen
and you know
it you can't climb stairs either okay
stop coming at my vehicle I'm just
kidding I know you can climb stairs oh
where do you think you're going you're
not off the hook yet buddy we got
Bridges to cross and all sorts of things
to complain about and again I could sit
here and harp on the story over and over
and over but you get the point right you
get the
point
[Music]
can your vehicle do that I didn't think
so like I said best damn vehicle in the
world a bomb flower you shouldn't have I
was running out but you get what I'm
saying about the story I mean it it
nothing from breath of the wild was
explained like we still don't know who
the the three dragons are we know that
if you swallow a secret Stone you become
a dragon that looks really really
similar so you know who swallowed the
secret stones to become those dragons
huh since the zonai are so and we still
don't know who the hell the zonai are
where' they come from are they aliens do
they literally come from off planet and
why did they take an interest in us why
did they leave but why did two of them
stay behind what why why why why why why
just so many things to wonder about but
you know since they're just so
mysterious and all knowing and all sorts
of you know jargon whatever then who's
to say that they weren't like the golden
goddesses aren't zonai themselves and
who's to say they didn't swallow their
own secret stones and become those three
dragons that are clearly named after
them faros nadra din rol what if that's
literally you know veror nou and din
like that's a ridiculous notion of
course but is it is it really the zonai
are clearly all powerful clearly choose
their own sages clearly can come up with
secret stones that can give people
Powers some people powers that can
shatter omnipotent rela relics like you
know the master sword like what where's
the
Triforce where where is it we didn't
know where it was in breath of the wild
some people were convinced that it was
in Zelda since you know the symbol
flashes on her hand but I don't I people
like me are not convinced with that
people like me need to know why it's
just resting in her bloodline now
instead of literally being an an
attainable Rel like it's always been
it's only ever rested in people's
Bloodlines when it was separated when it
when it needed protection it would
choose people as protectors and they
would be imbued with powers power going
to Ganondorf wisdom going to Zelda
courage going to
link if it's all in Zelda's bloodline
now why and and what point is that and
shouldn't that mean that she's all
powerful now because the completed
Triforce grants wishes ultimate wishes
and if it's not Zelda which I don't
believe it is where the heck is it and
of course the biggest one how do these
games fit into the timeline do they even
fit into the timeline is this a new
continuity if it is a new continuity why
do some Zora uh writings reference
Princess Ruto from ocarine of time why
does creating a champion talk about
ocarine of time's events as the distant
past why do we literally see some of the
temples from skyward Swords spread
around in Hyrule and why is everything
that's everything
that's anything that is anything ever
Zoni as I was saying in my original rant
video it's like Nintendo was watching
our videos about oh my God don't you
dare you you know what you know no
nobody hurt my vehicle anyway as I was
saying what was I saying where was I
where where what am I even talking about
what what is
anything oh yeah I was talking about the
fact that everything is zonai the
history of anything is is zonai Hell
there are even flashback cutscenes on
the great Plateau
where the Temple of Time like there's a
zonai Temple of Time which in and of
itself is just so weird but in the
flashbacks the zonai Temple of Time was
on the great Plateau where the current
Temple of Time
is and if you don't believe me I'm not
going to edit it on the screen or maybe
I will if I feel like it if you don't
believe me look it up like figure it out
for yourself I'm not lying the zonai
Temple of Time was where the current
Temple of Time is and the current Temple
of Time I
guess was built afterwards in the same
spot by hens for some
reason why I don't know I don't know
everything is so hard to explain because
nothing is nothing is explained and
everything is Zoni which is just the
dumbest explanation and the most easy
one that you could ask for and I don't
know a single person who's satisfied
with that who actually cares about the
story and what it leads to is everything
being just so gosh darn uninteresting
now everything nothing like
nothing matters
anymore and it's
sad don't you fall off don't you
freaking oh you
did it's okay I still love you I still
love you but nothing really matters
anymore and you can like it might matter
to a few of you watching this but
literally just look up like Google
Trends or look at look at the amount of
of lore videos being posted about this
game as opposed to before the game
released like it has completely killed
the hype behind wanting to know what's
going on in this universe because it
doesn't matter anymore because
everything is so convoluted it's either
way too complex to explain or it's not
explained at all or
both somehow both
It's A New Concept that this game
invented I don't know you guys I feel
like I've I've sufficiently what
the
aona
aona I guess I had left aona here from
uh who knows how long ago but hi girl
hey such a good girl just staying there
not moving a single in from where I left
you I was always coming back for you I
swear I was don't you believe anything
else don't you dare believe anything
else and see now that now that I'm
riding on top of a pona I have to I have
to change stuff around hold up hold up
this is
tradition this is tradition there we
go this is right this is
right and if you don't see the value in
this right here then I don't know what
to tell
you but anyway I could go on and on and
on and on but I feel like I have in in
this little ramble session I say little
but
it honestly if you've made it this far
congratulations you asked for this so
here it is I think what I want to do is
I want to talk about why this happened
like why why tears of the Kingdom
released and people got disappointed in
it like why why why was teers of the
Kingdom created this
way well to be honest with you I think
that I think that the success of breath
of the Wild and the style of game that
breath of the wild is has a lot to say
about why tears of the Kingdom came out
as essentially a copypaste version of
that
game see right after Sky's sword
released if you remember those of you
who have been in the franchise or in the
phandom for that long a lot of people
hated skyd
sword and you know it's kind of it's
disappointing of course because skyed
sword is a really good game
story-wise but gameplay-wise it was a
bit lacky not many people liked the
mechanics with the motion controls not
many people liked the backtracking that
you had to do to get through places or
to go back to the same area to do the
second dungeon in the same area and when
you were just trying to do that to have
like a segment where you're captured by
goblins and they take all of your stuff
like no nobody nobody liked that right
or the people who did are very very few
and far between so Skyward Sword was was
complained about quite a bit and
Nintendo if they've ever done anything
it's they listen to the fan base now
they might not always come up with very
good
Corrections based off of what they read
from the fan base and sometimes they
overcorrect but if there's one thing
they do it's they they listen to
feedback they've done that with all the
previous Zelda games Wind Waker was too
cartoony and so they went the complete
polar opposite way with Twilight
Princess and made the most dramatic
realistic looking Zelda to date in fact
in the files for Wind Waker oh is there
like an army up here I don't really want
to fight an
army but anyway in the files for Wind
Waker or for Twilight Princess it's
called Wind Waker 2 like seriously and
it has the Wind Waker object in there so
it was supposed to be a sequel to Wind
Waker but they listened to fans and
thought you know what what they want is
something more mature so after Skyward
Sword the biggest complaint that they
could hear was that Skyward Sword was
too
linear too trapped into going here at
this point and going there at this point
and whatever so in breath of the
wild they completely released everybody
so that you can do exactly what you want
to do when you want to do it doesn't
matter when doesn't matter where go in
whatever Direction the only thing you
have to do in breath of the wild is
complete the great Plateau segment after
that after you have your parag glider
who knows the world the world is your
oyster crack it open the biggest and
most popular Zelda game to date when you
take into account the 3D release of it
as well or 3Ds release of it as well is
Acron time besides the the breath of the
wild and onward so before breath of the
wild it was ocarine of time right Zelda
games had been living in ocarine of Time
shadow ever since and every game after
that was an ocarine of time like game
and then breath of the wild came out
reinvent the wheel and they were very
much so rewarded for it I think ocarine
of time plateaued around 14 million Sals
across all versions breath of the wild
is above 30 million currently so this
nonlinear break works right so Nintendo
did exactly the same thing with tears of
the kingdom and they didn't want and and
that led to all of the complaints that
I've been talking about with the story
and whatever personally I don't see a
problem with doing that necessarily but
I think that they could have handled it
a lot better I think they could have
written a story that was more cohesive
with breath of the
wild I think I don't think it's that
some people act like it's so difficult
to maintain a nonlinear open world
format and write a good story like I
I've literally read comments that are
like I don't know what you want from
them man like I don't know what you want
Nintendo to do like do you want a good
game or do you want a good story you got
to choose why do I have to
choose why is it that difficult is it
that difficult to write a story that
that that meshes with its own previous
lore news to me and I disagree I
fundamentally disagree because if it was
that difficult then the fans wouldn't
come up with such great fan theories and
fan stories that are all significantly
better than anything that happened in
this game and I think they should have
taken a lot more care into character ing
the new characters that they came out
with like for instance I I don't care
about the ancient sages especially after
those ridiculous God awful copy and
paste cutcenes
from can you can you actually rewatch
them
here no I don't think you can those copy
and paste cut scenes every time you
finish a dungeon you know what I'm
talking about I don't even know what to
say about those to be honest with you
because it's like that's just ridiculous
like that is that is just asinine to
release a game
where multiple actors say the same lines
about the same concept Demon King secret
Stone secret Stone Demon King Demon King
secret Stone literally
literally asinine asinine that that is
so far below Nintendo expectations that
I I'm I'm very disappointed and I will
probably never forgive them for that
one so clearly they should have spent
more time crafting a good story rather
than coming up with what they wanted to
do with the gameplay first and then
trying to fit a story in around that
they should have come up with the new
story first and then tried to fit the
gameplay around
that they were already going to get the
sales it's the sequel to breath of the
wild and speaking of new characters I
feel like they should have introduced
more new characters I don't think that
bringing Ganondorf back was a good idea
I'll just be honest with you I think
that the series has been screaming for a
new villain for a while like why is it
that Nintendo had to Outsource the
breath of the wild prequel game age of
Calamity which is non-canon of course
but hyro Warriors age of Calamity why
did they have to Outsource it to who is
it Konami I don't know who does the hyro
Warriors games but in order to get a new
villain for the Zelda series asor like
the Nintendo team couldn't come up with
a new villain and you know what asor was
pretty cool he was characterized pretty
cool actually to be honest with you the
story of age of Calamity is pretty cool
but again it's it's it's essentially a
fan story that people just wrote up and
because of that it's non-canon because
see when you create new characters and
you write new stories for these new
characters nobody has no old weird fans
like me have expectations for these
characters all of my disappointments in
Ganondorf were because he's not as cool
as the other versions of Ganondorf but
if it was a new character why should I
complain about that I don't know to
complain about that you could create a
new Bland character and I'd just be like
oh okay whatever and it would be at the
very worst neutral but now that you've
brought Ganondorf back and made him
Bland now it's a negative you see what I
mean come up with new characters because
then at the very very worst at the very
least they'll at least be uninteresting
but not a negative anyway i' I feel like
I've said my piece about this game I I
could I could go on I could write a
script and follow a scripted review but
I just I don't know when it comes to
reviewing games I'm not
a professional I've not really done this
that much in the past so I felt like
just turning the camera on and just
talking to you guys if that works and if
you're still watching this right
now you know what just like with the
Zelda rant video I really am not
expecting anybody to still be watching
this oh I don't have a bow of course but
if you are still watching this right
now leave a comment saying shoot that
whz
robe no don't leave that comment say say
nice shot if you're still watching this
say Nice Shot then I'll
know then I'll know but anyway I if you
are thank you for still watching I I
just after reading the feedback in a lot
of the comments from my Zelda rant video
I just I knew that I had to do something
like this and I had to just level with
you guys about how I felt about this
game and kind of explain
more about my thoughts behind my
disappointment with tears of the Kingdom
look a Restless Cricket I wonder where
I've seen that look A yiga Soldier oh
look he's dead I wonder where I've seen
these people from look a duplex bow I
wonder where I've seen that from before
you get the point you get the
point so with that you guys I feel like
I've said all I need to say I feel like
I don't need to go into this subject
anymore I feel like I have explained my
thoughts behind the zelder an
video and just re iterate and recap I
mean you can still go watch that video
if you want more of me rambling I don't
know why anybody would want that but if
you want more of me rambling you can
still go watch that video but just to
reiterate what I said there I am I'm
probably not going to be covering tears
of the Kingdom exclusively anymore in
videos at all I'll still cover Zelda
don't get me wrong but it'll be you know
Legacy Zelda games and of course tears
of the Kingdom will probably come up in
those videos but this is not going to be
a tears of the Kingdom channel it's not
going to be a breath of the wild Channel
this is going to be
a gaming lore Channel like I've always
wanted it to be and it's going to
incorporate other franchises Zelda
included and speaking of which let me
know what other franchises you want to
see covered in case you missed it there
were a lot of people who asked for
Metroid on the Zelda rant video I did
start off with a boss lore video for
Metroid Prime so check that out I'm
actually really proud of that one
um and that's it
I have here the last thing that I have
written on my uh little outline over
here is going forward what would I like
to see in the Zelda franchise and that's
something that actually now that I'm
thinking about it I would like to ask
you guys I know I keep asking you to
write comments but listen there's no
shame in leaving multiple comments on my
video all right I guarantee you I read
them uh but going forward what would you
like to see from the Zelda franchise and
of course I will weigh on in on this as
well I would still like to see
practically the same things that I
talked about at the end of uh breath of
the wild I would still like to see a
return to dungeons true dungeons not
these short
little see I haven't even gone into what
I thought about the
dungeons maybe what I need to do is just
live stream and talk about this stuff
you guys so so maybe I'll maybe I'll
live stream if you guys like that add
that into your thoughts about the future
of the Zelda franchise if you would like
for me to schedule a live stream where I
talk about just maybe I'll just walk
around in this game and talk to you guys
about it but anyway I'd like to see a
return to dungeons I'd like to see a
return to at least a somewhat linear
story like if the story was like Skyrim
like if if the open world was like a
Bethesda game where there is the main
story line that has to be progressed
through with the main
characters like and there are but it's
still open world world so you know you
can progress as you want to and there
are side quests and whatever I would
prefer that we do that which is really
what Zelda has been since the days of
like aine of time to be honest with you
like that's exactly what acarine of time
was that's what Twilight Princess was
that's what Wind Waker was that's what
Zelda has
been honestly I want to see a return to
that just in a world like
this and honestly the world doesn't
really have to be this big again like
they don't need to bust their butts
making a world this big every single
time or bigger they could go to half
this size to be honest with you and that
would be more than enough but I would
like to see a return to oh oh oh Lord oh
no it's a big bad hinox also another
thing that I don't get with this game is
why why there are still regular level
enemies
everywhere it makes it really hard to
find good horns when there are still red
level enemies like all over the place
you know what I mean you know what I
mean well easy peasy I didn't even get
to see his health
bar but you see what I mean this is like
this is the end of the game and I'm
still encountering enemies like
this that to me that's just that's just
that shouldn't happen that should have
been a much harder level enemy with a
lot better loot to be honest with you
but whatever I rest my case so yeah I'd
like to see return to dungeons I'd like
to see a return to the story or to the
kind of Storytelling I don't mind if
they introduce new things I don't mind
if they introduce something else that
can also break the master sword in the
next game or if they introduce another
blade entirely I don't mind so long as
it's a good story that's
it okay that's it you guys I'm done with
this subject and just in time to finish
my monster
that's to all of you for making it this
far go enjoy some video games go enjoy
Thanksgiving Happy Thanksgiving and uh
make sure you subscribe to the channel
got a lot more gaming lore videos to
come I'll be reading your comments to
look at whatever franchises you guys
want to see on the channel and uh yeah
we we this is not the end you guys this
is just a new beginning okay this is the
start of something really really cool
oh look he's looking at his hand I guess
that's one other new thing they added to
the game is a new Idol animation but
anyway this is the start of something
that can be really really cool all of us
venturing off into new franchises
together so let's do it
together if I started writing a book
series called The Tale of let's call it
the tale of
Zebulon and I wrote one book and then I
wrote another and called it the the tale
of Zebulon 2 and then I wrote another
and then another and then another and
they're all called The Tale of Zebulon
something 3 4 five the tale of Zebulon
essence of the Void whatever and within
those books I had references to the
other books that came before it or maybe
hints about books that might come in the
future you look me in the eyes and tell
me that you would not think those books
are connected and whose fault is that it
would be mine the authors right so here
we are again I know I keep making these
videos this is the third one of these
ramble rant type videos and after I went
live with those videos it really opened
the door for a lot of commenters to come
at me with a lot of arguments and I'm I
am a a Creator but I'm also a person you
may have noticed so I would like the
chance to defend myself a lot of people
watching right now and even if this
isn't you watching then I'll tell you
that these people exist a lot of fans of
many franchises but specifically for
this case fans of the Zelda franchise
get upset at people for being upset with
Nintendo for the way that they've
handled the lore in recent games and
that's fair it's fair to have differing
opinions it's fair to care more about
one thing or less about another there's
no problem with that I take issue though
with the argument that specifically
Nintendo never cared about the timeline
or never cared about the lore in their
Zelda games and that that was entirely
on us the fans back in the day
theorizing and and whatever it made we
forced Nintendo to create a timeline
where they never wanted to do it but we
held a gun to their heads and said you
connect these games or else we're not
buying your games anymore or whatever
and that's what I'd like to debunk in
this video and a couple disclaimers
number one as always I am a rambler
apologies in advance and number two
there will be spoilers in this video
probably maybe maybe not but here's a
theoretical spoiler warning for you
you're welcome so really this argument
that's been brought up about Nintendo
not caring about the Zelda timeline is
not a new one it's been there for the
entire time that my channel has been a
thing really I I I've seen these on
every timeline video I make or every
time that I even remotely criticize the
lore in the Zelda franchise I see these
comments just popping up but recently
they've been popping up all over the
place not just because of the ramble
videos that I uploaded but also because
there was a recent interview another one
that came out with the same people anuma
the producer of The Legend of Zelda
series and Fuji Bashi the director of
both breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom it's a new interview with game
inform for and it's a really cool
interview they're just asking about you
know what they're going to do with the
future of the franchise they actually
say something really cool in the
interview they say that Aluma says that
he refrains from commenting on a an
acine of time remake uh which could mean
that it's just such a tired subject he
doesn't want to talk about it or
obviously the elephant in the room is it
could mean that they are working on an
AAR of time remake which
would probably effectively break the
gaming world for a little bit but what I
want to focus on is let me find it real
quick they were asked pretty directly
about the timeline here it is when
you're developing a new Zelda title
obviously your primary focus is on core
gameplay but the timeline placement
discussion has become more important and
prevalent among the fans of the series
how much consideration and importance
does the development team put into those
discussions so clearly there have been
enough of us I guess at this point
talking about the timeline and talking
about the lore that even places like
Game Informer have taken notice and fuju
bash's answer is as follows as you
mentioned we realized that fans have a
great time theorizing and enjoy thinking
about where things fit on the timeline
cheers to that that's something that
that the development team recognizes and
it considers but to an extent and I say
to an extent because if we get too into
the weeds or too detailed in that
placement it results in kind of creating
restraints for our creativity the
process of creating new ideas becomes
restricted because we're so tied up and
trying to make this fit into a very
specific spot in the timeline we do
consider it but not to an extent where
we feel that our development process
feels restricted or
constrained there you have it folks
right off the bat we've got the answer
from the word of God Nintendo themselves
saying that Nintendo does not
necessarily care about the timeline
anymore and that much I agree with when
Link's Awakening came out the the Remake
it swapped its positioning on the
official Canon timeline from after the
Oracle games to before if I remember
correctly so that's actually something
that I agree with but what I take issue
with is the notion that they never cared
about the timeline or that it's the fans
fault for making the timeline a thing in
the first place in the first place if
you are the kind of fan who says that
Nintendo never cared about the Zelda
Timeline honestly you are kind of
ousting yourself a little bit as either
a fan who hasn't been here for all that
long or a fan who has been here but
hasn't really been paying attention from
the get-go the first Legend of Zelda was
much more detailed with its storytelling
than a game it's its sister game of
Super Mario or Donkey Kong as it
originally was called obviously in
Donkey Kong Mario formerly known as
Jumpman just scales a tower and saves
the girl from a big monkey in The Legend
of Zelda Link has to venture around and
find secret caves and has to find
upgrades to weapons and and other items
to use and battle all sorts of different
kinds of monsters and go through
dungeons in whatever order he feels like
and then retrieve the Triforce and
battle against a giant Pigman demon and
then save the princess it has a story in
its loading screen and if you have a
Nintendo switch with the Nintendo switch
Online subscription fire up your NES
launch The Legend of Zelda and just wait
for the loading screen to start playing
it reveals a story to you so right off
the bat the Legend of Zelda wanted to
tackle a more fantasy setting with a
story Zelda 2 came out out and it was a
sequel to The Legend of Zelda a sequel
to a game is a game that comes after a
game that's a timeline and really the
timeline of Zelda games was all centered
around Ganon back in the day the first
Legend of Zelda dealt with defeating
Ganon Legend of Zelda 2 or I'm sorry
just Zelda to the adventure of Link
dealt with preventing his resurrection A
Link to the Past was the first Zelda
game where they decided they were going
to do kind of a prequel because Link to
the Past is kind of a origin story for
ganet it explains where Ganon came from
in the manual that had never been done
before that point you even read that his
real life human name used to be Ganon
Dwarf dragmire so the fact that there
was a same the same villain who had
become this demonic two-legged Pig demon
who you can read used to be human in the
booklet for the game meant that it was
really supposed to be a prequel and
people put those dots together they
connected those dots Link's Awakening
came out which was the same kind of
thing that Zelda 2 was to the original
Legend of Zelda links Awakening was a
sequel to A Link to the Past it was that
link from that game continuing his
Adventure then aaring of time came out
and we got a prequel to A Link to the
Past because now we got to see Ganondorf
dragmire and then we legitimately get to
see Ganondorf become Ganon and if you're
following me so far it's really not that
hard to explain the games keep coming
out in their kind of prequels the the
original Legend of Zelda was always
supposed to be kind of the most
futuristic one they kept coming out
explaining the history of Ganon in some
other way fans connected the dots
because there were dots to be connected
placed there by Nintendo but then as you
know acarine of time is where things got
kind of funky because at the end of
ocarine of time the timeline splits and
they always knew the timeline was going
to split and we have two evidences for
that one wind waker the beginning of
Wind Waker directly explains link
popping into that timeline when he drew
the master sword in aine of time and
popped into the adult timeline and then
popping out of it after he defeats Ganon
that is directly explained in the intro
segment of the Wind Waker and the second
thing I wanted to talk about were the
several different interviews from the
early 2000 late
1990s where mamoto and anuma both talked
directly about the Zelda timeline in
1999 mamoto was asked by an interviewer
that and this interview was included in
apparently the original aine of time
booklet he was asked uh before it was
released Nintendo announced that this
new Nintendo 64 Zelda could unlock the
Mysteries of the entire Zelda story
could you tell us about that in your own
words to which mamoto responded maybe
Mysteries was a bit of an exaggeration
but you do learn the story of where the
Triforce came from and it is meant to be
episode one of the Zelda Saga the basic
ORD Ocarina then the original Legend of
Zelda followed be by a link to the past
which obviously is not really how the
Legend of Zelda Timeline as we know it
today is laid out but back in the day
that was Moto's understanding in the
same interview he goes on to say that
that on the importance of like story and
continuity between the games right now
our highest priority is to create an
interesting game first and foremost
sometimes that means not worrying about
the joints not lining up perfectly which
is inevitable anyway excluding really
obvious big breaks in continuity we
ignore the little inconsistencies this
interview explains both points it
explains that one it's true mamoto and
Co were not super super concerned about
making sure everything lined up however
he was concerned with making things line
up in the big picture way in the big
timeline way he goes on to say for that
reason I've often been accused of not
caring about the story but when I
consider the medium of video games above
intra series continuity it's far more
important to me that the player is left
with a satisfying aftertaste once the
experience is over and only to that
extent do I care about continuity in
that huge breaks with Canon or previous
games would make players feel betrayed
and we don't want that as you can see he
directly talks about the fact that a lot
of people do accuse him for not caring
about the story and only caring about
experience to which he responded
essentially I mean kind of mostly but
not entirely He does care about
experience first and foremost and he's a
freaking Visionary he came up with Mario
he came up with Zelda we need people who
think about experiences first and
foremost obviously but part of that
experience to him as you just heard is
Canon continuity says once again huge
breaks with Canon or previous games
would make players feel betrayed and we
don't want that what I'm trying to say
is that Nintendo themselves created the
timeline that's all I'm trying to prove
here I'm not I it's both right of course
a lot of people were clamoring to figure
out the secrets of the timeline back in
1997 when they were giving commercials
for aine of time that's when they said
unravel the mysteries of the Zelda
franchise excuse me and there were only
four games out before then and they were
all pretty easy to understand as far as
fitting in between one another or
whatever and they did make the choice to
name each of them Zelda games so they
knew they knew that people were going to
be trying to connect them one to another
they're the ones who created that
situation and I know I keep I keep
repeating this I feel like I've repeated
that 20 times but I'm just I'm trying to
say it to where you will hear me
Nintendo created the timeline they
wanted to now they did not want to put
all that much of an effort into making
it consistent 100% me me personally this
is where I kind of don't understand
what's up with that a little bit because
to me I feel like those don't have to be
two separate Concepts you don't have to
only focus on experience of a game or
whatever without focusing on the story
and the lore whatever or vice versa you
don't only have to focus on the story
and the lore and then like you just have
a boring game that doesn't matter or
whatever the argument that that was
brought up in the recent 2023 interview
with anuma and fuu bayashi and Game
Informer that
Nintendo would be constricting their
creativity restricting it within the
timeline if they focused on it too much
is I think I think a little flawed
because if you think about it is the
Legend of Zelda not already a
constriction their universe that they
created is that not already a
constriction the fact that they will not
make Zelda playable
after Decades of people asking for it is
that not already a constriction that
they are refusing to push through they
will not give up the balance of Link and
Zelda and evil the balance of the three
forces is that not a restriction but
within that restriction they've been
able to come up with some pretty damn
Creative Concepts I mean Zelda herself
has been how many different things
across the franchise Sheik tetra hilia
and then obviously all the unique things
that happened with her in breath of the
wild and tears of the Kingdom all within
the Restriction of no playable Zelda and
Zelda not being an immediate part of the
story the whole time and playing through
large portions of the game without her
they can focus on working within
restrictions and working within preset
patterns it just has to be one that they
want to focus on and for some reason
they don't want to focus on the timeline
and if I may critique Nintendo just a
little bit here I think that's a little
illogical or not illogical but a little
uninspired because listen if you give an
artist a blank canvas to work with or if
you give a writer a new franchise to
work with whatever is written whatever
is drawn whatever is painted whatever
colors they use or don't use whatever
all of it is 100% creative is it not
because there was nothing there before
however if you
introduce restraints and restrictions
and then give someone the Liberty to
create something based off of that in my
opinion that's what inspires true
creativity and to be honest with you I
also find it a little hard to believe
that it is just that difficult it's just
that difficult to write a story within
the constraints of the universe that
you've already created I mean Middle
Earth does it pretty well Star Wars well
okay maybe not Star Wars but Metroid the
Metroid franchise does it really well
it's not impossible you can create one
continuous story story honestly the
Zelda franchise has the perfect setup
for it they just snap their fingers and
100 to 10,000 plus years will just
evaporate in between games you can do so
many different things with that you can
leave Hyrule go to a different land I
don't even have time to get into the
thousands of fresh creative ideas that
can be implemented while into the Zelda
franchise while working within the
constraints of the established lore and
the established universe so to me that's
a choice from Nintendo that I don't
necessarily understand but I digress
just to recap this whole all of my
rambling has really made two major
points one Nintendo did create the
timeline whether or not it was from
goating from fans or whatever Nintendo
created the timeline and two Nintendo
already restricts themselves in other
ways just not with the timeline
apparently and honestly I don't think
the timeline was all that difficult to
understand initially there were only
supposed to be two timeline splits off
of acarine of time with Ganon being
created and then as mamoto explained
with it then going on to lead into the
original Legend of Zelda and then Zelda
2 and then a link to the past and then
links Awakening and that's that's pretty
easy to understand and even once Major's
mask came out things were still pretty
easy to understand because there was a
split at the end of aine of time into
the child and adult timelines But as
time went on they didn't want to leave
Ganon and Ganon Dwarf as villains behind
and they kept making games with him as
the villain which became harder and
harder to interpret into this timeline
that at one point was pretty easy to
understand and for the games that were
the most difficult to understand like a
link to the past especially since Ganon
is said to or is shown to be defeated at
the end of acarine of time in both
timelines once they placed a link to the
past in the Fallen timeline and then all
of the other games that they couldn't
explain their timeline placement also in
the Fallen timeline I think that's where
all of the tension started to come from
because the Fallen timeline doesn't make
sense and I've talked about this before
adult timeline child timeline those are
legitimate splits that you can
understand because of the end of ocarine
of time but the Fallen timeline is
another reality it's the reality where
link dies at the end of ocarine of time
he's not able to defeat Ganon or Ganon
dworf depending on which one he's
fighting at the time obviously if you
have beaten aine of time then that is
not canon but the fact that the Fallen
timeline exists means that it is can
Cannon so that's why things started to
get I feel a little a little icky and
for a lot of people who saw that and saw
that it didn't really make sense they
started to be much more vocal about the
fact that oh it's the fans's fault it's
not Nintendo's fault Nintendo would
never make a mistake like that it's the
fans's fault the fans are the ones who
created the timeline in the first place
and the fans are the ones who are now
messing it up and that is why I made
this entire freaking video just to prove
to people once and for all to point back
to this video whenever these comments
inevitably come up in the future that
yes fans were excited about the timeline
and connecting the dots in between games
because there were dots to be connected
and because there was a timeline as
proven in the '90s from mamoto but fans
are not the ones who messed it up I
think the fatal error was making the
decision to include a timeline in The
Legend of Zelda but not actually focus
on it and going forward for game
franchises I think that if you're going
to create lore I think that you need to
make it a decision off the bat if you're
going to pay attention to that lore
because if you're not going to why even
make a sequel in the same game series
just make a new franchise it's been
nearly 40 years I don't think they're
ever going to drop the name The Legend
of Zelda but I think that they should
drop the timeline personally I think
they should drop the Continuum I think
that they should put their money where
their mouths are because in that in the
Game Informer interview yeah see in in
this interview they were asked uh does
the highy roll we saw in the flashback
scenes and tears of the Kingdom predate
Skyward Sword or does it come after the
games in the timeline and this is one of
the most infamous answers that they gave
in this entire interview Fuji bayashi
says obviously there's something a bit
clearer in our minds but of course it
could be that we're wrong as well I kind
of want to pose the idea that like in
real life history you defined by the
artifacts and by the data that you
currently have and I wasn't aware that
you know real life history is just so
malleable but apparently it is so within
what we have there might be a correct
answer but it could be a different
answer so I guess my answer would be
that it could be both both could be
correct and auma chimed in and said I
mean the Legend of Zelda is a series of
games that focuses on puzzle solving so
this is just another sort of puzzle that
the users will have to see if they can
solve and think about for people who are
diard fans of the lore that might be a
frustrating answer because basically
they threw their hands in the air and
went I don't know doesn't really matter
it's up to people to think about but
honestly I I'm not mad about that
because I that's what I'm saying should
happen drop the timeline let let the
fans who who care about the timeline
come up with the timeline and work with
it and like just have like a fan a fan
in Timeline because at this point the
dozens of timeline theories out there
work a lot better than what is Canon
especially since it switches around and
especially since the very creators of
the series and developers of the series
themselves say really it's up to the
fans to interpret how they want so I
think they should put their money where
their mouth is and do that drop the
Canon timeline stop these arguments
between or among fans about whether or
not Nintendo cared about it in the first
place or whatever and just let us ride
it
ourselves so anyway that's it I just
wanted to make the final of these ramble
Trilogy videos about responding to what
began with tears of the Kingdom
criticism and what is now ending with
timeline criticism again I would like to
reiterate I love the Legend of Zelda as
a franchise it is my favorite gaming
franchise to date I love breath of the
wild I really liked tears of the Kingdom
nothing wrong with loving either of
those games or or not loving the
franchise as whole there's nothing wrong
with whatever opinion you have right now
and there's nothing wrong with my
opinion but I just wanted to set the
record straight so I made this video but
of course as I'm ending I want to just
ask you people what do you think should
happen with the Zelda Timeline do you
think that it needs to be redone by
Nintendo just reoriented with official
placements for breath of the wild and
tears of the Kingdom finally and maybe
even other non-canon games like the hyru
Warriors games placed on the timeline
finally or do you think that they should
do you agree with me and think that they
should release the Canon timeline back
to the fans put their money where their
mouth is like they say in interviews and
let us figure it out let me know in the
comments below I'm probably not going to
do another one of these ramble type
videos for a while unless there's a
topic that I feel passionate enough
about but if you're still watching thank
you so much for watching just like I've
done with the other two videos here's my
little test for you if you're still
watching say my favorite Zelda game is
and then with your Zelda your favorite
Zelda game in a comment below you can
also comment whatever else you want
under that but make that the first line
if you're still
watching The Legend of Zelda is in an
odd spot at the moment it's not broken
per se but it is very different from
what the series used to be and because
of this we've got fans on the one side
defending it to the death and we've got
fans on the other side attacking it to
the death now watching my recent videos
you might think I'm one of the latter
but you'd actually be surprised my take
on the current state of Z Zelda is quite
simple I defend the parts of the games
that I like and criticize the parts that
I don't there are definitely fans on
either side of this argument that are
much more passionate about their sides
than I am but no matter what side you're
on if you're watching this right now you
can breathe a sigh of
relief big Bandits here to fix all this
I believe there exists an idea for the
next Zelda game that if implemented
would appease both attackers and
Defenders of the current Legend of Zelda
20 ideas to be specific let us begin
number one I think it would be a good
idea to rework the current weapon system
I've never been one of those people that
absolutely despises the weapon system
that was introduced in breath of the
wild I think that this is a fine Concept
in and of itself I think that a lot of
other open world games use the same kind
of durability concept for their weapons
I just think that it could be massively
improved upon I think Nintendo needs to
rebalance it from the ground up I think
that more powerful weapons need to be a
lot more rare to find and consequently I
think that weapons need to to have a lot
more durability just on average I'm not
saying that every bobblin out there
that's carrying a Boo bat should no
longer drop their booat that would be
unrealistic and I actually like the fact
that if you can see an enemy using a
weapon they drop said weapon that's a
great gameplay mechanic in my opinion
what I'm saying is that there should be
a lot fewer more powerful weapons out
there giving players fewer more powerful
weapons would make those weapons a lot
more valuable and subsequently I think
the same kind of thing could be
implemented for tears of the Kingdom's
new weapon system which is to say the
for ing system I love it personally it's
just simple enough to keep things fresh
I just think again that they could do a
lot more with it maybe multiple items
can be fused into a weapon maybe there
can be more effects than what we've
currently seen maybe some items fused
onto a weapon can repair that weapon
some items fused onto a weapon can
increase its durability or you can
combine a durability increase with an
electric mushroom something like that to
zap your enemies but also keep your
weapon for longer the possible
combinations would be endless but
speaking of new combinations and new
weapons what if the new Zelda game
introduced new weapons entirely so in
breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom there are three kinds of melee
weapons one-handed two-handed quick and
two-handed slow and yes link will swing
them at different speeds or maybe
slightly different lead depending on
like if you have a blunt weapon as
opposed to a sharpened weapon but that
doesn't change the fact that there are
only three very basic weapon types out
there I would love to see link able to
wield of course Spears and swords but
what about bigger swords or smaller
swords like daggers what about dual
wielding what about hammers or a giant
mace what about a Ballin chain or a
smaller handheld one called a Morning
Star what about a whip what about new
kinds of bows like great bows or
crossbows and here's a thought that I'll
kind of go into a little bit more later
on but what about introducing new
legendary weapons for link to wield what
if for instance you could stumble across
ganon's Trident and these other
legendary weapons would Grant special
abilities and I know I've been rambling
about weapons for a while and trust me
the other points on this list are not
going to take nearly this much time but
weapons is such a broad subject I really
needed to just put all my thoughts out
there the last thing I'll say about it
is I think that weapons should be
repairable I think this is something
that people have complained about since
breath of the wild in 2017 and it's
definitely something that should have
been an addition to tears of the Kingdom
which was not sadly I understand that
Nintendo felt that being able to repair
your weapons would hurt the mechanic
that they were going for which is
continually just keep exploring keep
finding weapons keep swapping to new
ones and whatnot but if you implement a
durability mechanic that could
accomplish the same thing sure you might
have a great weapon sure you might
really like using that weapon sure it
might have cost you an arm and a leg to
get that weapon but once its durability
hits zero you can't use it anymore got
to go get it repaired and in the
meantime you have to find the other
weapons that you've picked up it could
work it should work and it would
definitely help fix the next Legend of
Zelda for everybody next up speaking of
reworking things I think that the entire
eating mechanic in Zelda should be
reworked I do enjoy the addition of Link
being able to eat things in order to
regenerate health and Achieve different
status effects but we've got to be
honest with ourselves the moment that
they introduced Health regeneration as a
solely making link eat things mechanic
they removed collecting hearts and this
might be my Nostalgia talking or it
might just be the argument of a
different style of game but I kind of
miss having to look for hearts
furthermore I think that giving link the
ability to just pause the game at any
point and eat 1 million apples at any
given point and regenerate unlimited
amounts of Health was kind of a change
for the worse it made things a bit too
easy the only real way that you'll get
killed in this game is if you fall off
of something or if something hits you
hard enough in the older Zelda games if
you were really struggling with a fight
and you were out of potions or you just
couldn't find any hearts around you all
the pots were gone the grass was gone
the smaller enemies to kill for hearts
were all gone then you were kind of out
of luck but It's tricky because I on the
other hand do enjoy all of the various
cooking and effects that link is able to
get from eating things in breath of the
wild and tears of the Kingdom so what do
we do in the next Zelda game to
implement maybe both of these systems
well I'm glad you asked for one example
of how to handle this I would like to
reference genin impact now for those of
you who have played the game you
probably know what I'm talking about but
if you haven't in genin Impact it has a
very similar pause the game eat
something to regenerate your
characters's health mechanic however
your characters can't just eat a million
things at any given point they have an
appetite and if they're full and can't
eat anymore then they're full and they
can't eat anymore therefore it's a hard
cap on how many things you can stuff
down the gullet of your characters it is
a little odd that link can eat 500
apples 200 mushrooms and three
multi-course meals in any given instant
I mean I'm sure he's got a fast
metabolism but that's a little freaky
and maybe we could flesh this out a
little bit more maybe not all meals are
created equal maybe a smaller just
chicken chicken on a stick meal could
take up this much of his appetite but a
full coar big Grand turkey could take up
this much of his appetite and the
effects would differ as well this only
regenerates one heart this regenerates
five and in the meantime you could also
find hearts in Grass pots or on minor
enemies all over Hyrule I could see it
working very well actually and potions
on the other hand could not take up any
appetite because you know you can always
drink right number three and perhaps the
most obvious of all of them we need a
new map traversing this current land of
Hyrule has been fun and it's so big and
so vast that they even used it again in
tears of the Kingdom just with some
added sky islands and an added depths
area The Legend of Zelda has always had
a day night cycle at least ever since
aine of time but you know what none of
the Zelda games have ever had and I'll
get a bit more into this a bit later on
they've never had seasons and I think
this is because there have always been
the winter air areas the summer areas in
the same map of Hyrule what if there are
multiple maps that you can travel in
between multiple States if you will and
here's another thing about the new map
that we're going to need going forward
should links Spider-Man climbing ability
return if you think about it it affects
everything it affects how intricately
Nintendo designs every single angle of
their Maps it affects puzzle design and
many more factors of the game personally
I don't think that it's necess
I have enjoyed climbing ever so slowly
up the side of whatever in the world I
wanted to if I had enough cooked stala
shrooms in my bag but at the same time
there is an Irreplaceable mechanic that
is lost when anything can be scaled it's
the very mechanic that they inject back
into the games whenever link does a
shrine for instance Nintendo just said
nope you can no longer climb in here
because if you can climb over everything
that ruins like half of the puzzle ideas
out there so I see there as being
several benefits to removing Spider-Man
climbing for Link in the next Zelda game
Nintendo can take more time to focus on
designing other elements of the game or
they can take more time to design more
map in general while not necessarily
having to design it with quite as much
verticality as they did every single
inch in the current world of Hyrule
another slight thing that I would like
to see in the next map wherever it may
be hyru or not is the addition of
wandering bosses think about it we've
got world bosses already and they've
been implemented very well you can
Target exactly where a gly is exactly
where a hinox is exactly where a stone
Talis is if they do roam it's within
their little section I understand that
that might be more difficult in general
but it would be pretty cool it would
make the world feel really alive for an
example of a game that accomplishes this
very well think of Elden ring and yes
Elden ring is a significantly more
difficult game than Zelda ever has been
but the concept could still be
implemented I think in a way that's not
quite as inaccessible for casual gamers
number four another very big one that's
close to my heart bring back pieces of
heart I understand why they removed
pieces of heart from the game because
they wanted to make a purchasable system
for heart containers and stamina vessels
which worked but let me paint you a
picture imagine you walk into a village
let's call it kakaro Village and you
walk into a house and in the corner of
this house there's a cage and Inside the
Cage is a cow and a piece of heart it's
right there you can't enter the cage
though how do you get it you're left to
wonder and puzzle and think outside the
box and this isn't even a dungeon puzzle
this is just in the world of Hyrule
somewhere that very scenario that I just
painted is one of the most famous pieces
of heart to collect in Ocarina of Time
in kakaro village and it is a staple of
the Zelda series something being dangled
right in front of you just Out Of Reach
that you'll have to think very hard
about how to get to and I think that
they could be added back to the next
Zelda game even if Nintendo wanted to
bring back this multi hundred Shrine
setup that they have loved since breath
of the wild let's say there are 200 new
shrines in the next game what if at the
end of each of them they don't each give
you the same thing an orb of blessing or
an orb of light or whatever they're
called but instead some of them will
give you a piece of heart and some of
them will give you a piece of stamina
and some would give you other rewards
entirely very rare weapons very rare
potions rare pieces of gear and they
could also add back in pieces of Harden
the world of hyu at large put one in a
tree have a flying enemy around carrying
one in their talons and you got to
figure out how to get up to it and knock
it down and leave the solution up to the
player adding pieces of heart back into
the game could work so easily and should
work and would still appease all kinds
of fans out there number five one of the
most requested things since breath of
the wild came out the return of dungeons
I know what you're thinking but Bandit
didn't they bring dungeons back in tears
of the Kingdom no well they did I guess
but you know they were just the same as
the Divine beasts and I guess you could
call them dungeons but when people ask
for the return of Zelda dungeons they're
talking about much longer experiences
that are much more notable much more
memorable with a lot more puzzles
involved but I'm not just slamming my
fists on the table like an old nostalgic
fan saying bring me back what I was used
to I don't like this new stuff I'm here
to tell you what if they brought back
dungeons in a new way here are a couple
ideas branching off of that Seasons
changing idea that I had a little bit
ago what if some dungeons were ephemeral
which is to say temporarily accessible
imagine there's a dungeon on top of the
frozen icy mountain and you can only
access it in the spring summer or fall
because in Winter it is way too cold to
go up there the entire pathway is just
iced over and believe it or not link can
no longer just climb up the side of
Frozen freaking ice anymore and it's way
too cold for any fire to melt it or what
if the dungeon underneath Death Mountain
is only accessible in the winter because
in the spring summer or fall things are
just way too hot Link's skin sets on
fire just trying to enter the area or
get this what if there's a Temple that
just so happens to be underwater that's
only accessible in the spring or the
fall maybe this Lake that it's
positioned in is in between deaf
mountain and the icy mountain and in the
summer it's too hot to enter the water
and in the winter the water freezes over
and that's just one element of ephemeral
dungeons there could be dungeons that
slip in and out of time there could be
dungeons that slip in and out of reality
there could be dungeons that will
levitate into the sky for some jargon
lore reason I'm just saying if you
brought in ephemeral dungeons that would
shake things up quite a bit and here's
another way to implement new dungeons do
you know what a Rog like is for those of
you who don't a Rog like game is a game
that's essentially a Dungeon Crawler but
every level that you enter has
randomized enemies and therefore
randomized loot that is temporary for
that run you get as far into it as you
can and often times there is an end
there is a last level a last boss and
that may or may not be randomized but if
you fail you reset your progress all the
way to the start and you lose all of
your temporary Buffs that you were
collecting along the way what if The
Legend of Zelda had a rogu likee dungeon
think the master sword trials but
randomized and there are so many ways to
fit a Rog likee dungeon into the lore
but I digress the next thing that could
fix the next Legend of Zelda would be
new playable modes slash situations
slash events that break up the
monotonous gameplay so here's what I
mean by that in breath of the wild and
tears of the Kingdom you play your first
segment of the game where it teaches you
the mechanics of the game you you get
your powers that you'll use in the game
and that's it you use this same style of
gameplay this formula that you have
learned for link in every circumstance
but in past Zelda games Twilight
Princess for instance there were so many
different spots where the game play was
broken up to introduce something urgent
or just different like spoiler alert for
the game Sorry but there is a moment in
the game where you have to save midna's
life she's on your back dying you have
to race to the Castle or when you have
to do the escort mission for the dying
Zora Prince or when you have the duels
on the bridge leading to the most
kickass shot of Link in the entire
franchise to date breath of the wild and
tears of the kingdom do have some of
these broken up modes of gameplay but
normally they're related to maybe a side
quest or something like that I would
like to see a bit more grandure of a
concept being enacted for maybe the main
story or something along those lines
number seven we we need active
companions to make a return I'm talking
na'vi from Ocarina of Time I'm talking
midna from Twilight Princess I'm talking
the king of red lions from Wind Waker
I'm talking fee from Skyward Sword for
most of the most popular Zelda games out
there link has a companion this
companion character gives advice
comments on things tells link what to do
reminds him what his current status is
again to reference a game that enacts
this very Concept in a very wellth
thought out way albeit I'm not the
biggest fan of this character genin
impact Pon that's an open world game
that has a bunch of quests and different
things that you can do but Pimon follows
you around everywhere and comments on
everything and doesn't stop I'm not
saying the character has to be annoying
I'm just saying that it would be nice to
have a companion character and here's
another element to that what if you
could choose your companion character
what if there were a bunch of choices
like the older companions from The
Legend of Zelda franchise midna na'vi
fee and you could choose which one of
them you want to explore the world with
and each each of them had unique things
they would say and unique pieces of
dialogue prompting you to really try
each of them out and different
relationships with link or you could
choose to have none of them and just go
it alone without anybody talking in your
ear I think everybody would be a fan of
that idea Nintendo number eight new or
old lore now if that sounds confusing
good the reason why I said that is
because this would be the only way to
appease everybody in One Fell Swoop and
all it takes Nintendo if you're
listening is to make a choice either a
connect the lore from the next Zelda
game to the franchise not connecting all
the pieces but leaving pieces to be
connected that Mak sense or be don't
connect anything at all do something new
entirely have the only reference to
previous Zelda games be the existence of
Link and Zelda choose one or the other
of these approaches to the story and
lore of the next game but do not
sacrifice a good narrative trying to do
both and on honestly personally I'm
leaning more towards the side of do
something new entirely I mean it's very
obvious isn't it breath of the wild and
tears of the Kingdom aren't even
connected to the timeline they've
already set the building blocks up to
separate the next Zelda game entirely
from everything that came before so
honestly I think they should number nine
I believe everybody would benefit from
the appearance of a new villain the
Zelda series will most likely never come
out from under the shadow of Ganon he's
iconic he's big he's scary he's
beautiful we love him but I'm going to
level with you here Ganon or Ganon Dwarf
as a character is now generic in every
way in the first place he's not just one
character anymore he's multiple he can
reincarnate as another version of
himself so therefore it's not Ganondorf
it's a Ganondorf and secondly and this
one is a bit more factual Ganondorf
doesn't have to have a backstory he can
just show up and be I hate hyru
I want to take everything for myself
because that is what a king must do
which is the most generic villain thing
I've ever heard so let's not ruin his
legacy or do something with it that
would piss anybody off let's just
introduce a new villain new villains
have been introduced in the series
before and typically they go over pretty
well you look at me right now and tell
me you did not absolutely adore
geim I know you did geim was amazing and
gim's relation to demise was amazing
everybody loved Zant of course some
people have complains about how he
turned out at the end but everybody
loved Zant even the non-canon villains
like what's his face asor he was pretty
freaking cool madus vti Yuga the list
goes on and on and I think that
everybody would benefit from a new Zelda
villain number 10 the return of
underwater gameplay honestly I don't
think I even need to go into this all
that much enough said I think everybody
whether a defender or an attack ER of
the current state of Zelda games Ms
underwater traversal it was one of the
weirdest things to remove from the era
of the wild although everybody
understands why it's simply because it
would have been too much for the
development team but I don't know about
you I would trade probably a good half
of the map of hyru if it meant good
old-fashioned underwater puzzles
dungeons traversal you name it combat
whatever bring it back Nintendo bring it
back number 11 I don't I don't have
enough fingers for any of the other ones
meaningful items listen for you new
Zelda fans there used to be meaningful
gadgets and spells and tools back in the
day that link could use I'm talking the
shovel the spinner Ballin chain Pegasus
Boots the power bracelet magical rods
masks the hook shot the gust Bellows
each of these served to enhance the
gameplay unlock new areas new methods of
combat methods of traversal you name it
and we're all replaced for Link's
arsenal of sandbox powers like magnesis
or ultrahand but I think especially if
Nintendo were to do what I was talking
about earlier and remove Link's
Spider-Man crawling abilities that it
would be a very welcome addition
especially for traversal and think about
the musical instruments oh man link used
to have such cool musical instruments in
in addition to the Ocarina IM maor's
masy had a guitar he had drums he had a
bagpipe things and Skyward Sword he had
a harp in Twilight Princess he could
Howl in Wind Waker he had the Wind Waker
which was a baton that could conduct the
notes of the wind and each of these
magical instruments were used for
warping were used for changing night to
day or day to night calling upon a storm
you name it I think link should have a
musical instrument in the next game
maybe one that he can choose I think
that magic should return so in breath of
the wild and tears of the Kingdom right
you pick up a fire arrow you fire that
fire arrow now you you have no fire
arrows in the older Zelda games you
learned the ability to magically create
fire arrows and you could fire them out
there so long as you had arrows and
magic and bringing magic back would open
the door to all sorts of different
spells you could bring back Ocarina of
Time style spells like Den's fire or you
could introduce new ones like imagine if
link could heal himself with magic power
I find it very hard to imagine the kind
of person that would have a problem with
this addition in the next Zelda game
number 12 bring back empty bottles empty
bottles were a whole other mechanic
that's just not there at all in breath
of the wild or tears of the kingdom and
you can still have your magical
unlimited inventory but bottles were at
least one form of inventory management
that actually made sense and that nobody
had a problem with you had to choose
whether or not you wanted to store a
health potion or a magic potion or a
potion very expensive that would restore
both or if you wanted to catch a fairy
or back in aine of time if you wanted to
catch some bugs or if you wanted to
catch a fish or if you wanted to catch
some water it was an inventory mechanic
that was cool and I think it should be
brought back and also they were powerful
enough to defeat Ganondorf yeah bring
them back number 13 a playable story you
know what I mean by that in breath of
the wild you don't play through the
story like we all thought we were going
to when we first saw the trailers no all
of that happened 100 years prior to the
game's events now we've all cried over
it if we were going to cry over it or
not that's been a long time ago and it's
not that breath of the Wild's story was
not good it was it was actually it was
great I just did a video covering the
kings of Hyrule and when I covered Rome
BOS fama's Hyrule I got sad because it's
a really good story but we didn't get to
play through it and when tears of the
Kingdom came out they kind of teased us
a little bit with Ganondorf being right
there in front of Lincoln Zelda after
the events of breath of the wild meaning
this is something that's going to be
happening as of our control of the
characters of the game and it starts and
you see Ganondorf and things happen and
then everything already happened in the
past exactly like breath of the wild you
do not get to play through it you do not
get to experience any of it you just
find it out again and if you think about
it the last time that a Zelda game had a
story that had events that you actually
play through was over 10 years ago in A
Link Between Worlds it's been over a
decade it's time and speaking of the
story number 14 give us a linear and
nonlinear combo of gameplay that can
actually work it's a very simple concept
that they've been implementing ever
since ever since the start to be honest
with you think about a link to the past
how many nonlinear things can you do at
any point in the game play that just
pauses the linear story and doesn't
affect its progression they did the same
thing in Ocarina they did the same thing
in Majora's Mask they did the same thing
in Wind Waker they did the same thing in
Twilight Princess they did the same
thing in skyd sword and and it's not
just Zelda games most open world games
do this Oblivion Skyrim The Fallout
games even MMOs World of Warcraft Final
Fantasy Elden ring this is however one
that I'm not sure that anuma will be
very open to in a recent interview as
you might remember he stated that he
doesn't really want there to be stories
in games anymore and I'm not sure if
this was taken out of context or what
but it's definitely a strange take that
does kind of make sense given his
decisions with the stories in the last
few years he wants there to be a story
that players kind of make themselves in
a sandbox world like I said it could
have been taken out of context so I'm
just going to put a pin in that and not
come back to it but speaking of a create
your own concept though number 15 what
if the next Zelda game implemented a
diverging storyline the era of the Wild
games have already had multiple endings
depending on how many things you
completed in the game what if this was
just an evolution of that concept again
to reference another game series that
that does this very well the souls
series Elden ring Dark Souls bloodborne
demon souls or heck the Five Nights at
Freddy's games there are always multiple
endings that depend on your choices even
though there's only ever one that's
actually the Canon ending it still
doesn't matter though because it feels
rewarding to a player to have a
different path through the game as
another player that was different
because of your choices I'm not saying
you should be able to make link a
villain unless Nintendo really wanted to
think outside the box for the next game
but the ability to alter what does or
doesn't happen by The Game's end might
be a very welcome addition let the
players create their own stories right
number 16 we need a lot more enemies I
know that tears of the Kingdom brought
some new enemies into the fold like the
flux constructs or the froes or the gleo
I kind of don't want to do this because
I'm not that proud of this video but in
a relatively recent retrospective I did
about breath of the wild I compared the
number of different kinds of monsters
that you can encounter in breath of the
wild to other Zelda games and I'm just
going to let you have a listen to that
early game you get used to fighting any
one of these kinds of enemies the only
real difference between their colors is
their health pool here's a little frame
of reference for you in breath of the
wild and I'm going to refer to my notes
Here There are 98 total different
enemies that includes World bosses and
all the versions of Ganon as well but
when you cut out the duplicates like you
know the multiple colors or the multiple
different kinds of the same enemy that
are just different elements you are left
with 28 eight different kinds of enemies
in the game for comparison in ocarine of
time you know a game that came out 19
years before breath of the wild there
were 87 total different enemies in the
game or 64 when you cut out the
duplicates that's well over twice the
amount of unique enemies in breath of
the wild in Twilight Princess which came
out 12 years before breath of the wild
there were 107 total enemies or 84
unique different kinds of enemies when
you cut out the duplicates that is
literally three times the amount in
breath of the Wild but yeah breath
of my point is we just need a lot more
different kinds of enemies to fight in
the next Zelda game I think this is
something that the series set as a
standard and then kind of went back on
quite a bit because they spent more time
developing the map itself in breath of
the wild and tears of the kingdom and
it's definitely something that can just
be changed they don't even have to
develop a lot of new enemies just bring
back all the old enemies that we've been
missing bring back skulas bring back
stalos
bring back tech tights or make new ones
and obviously I could go on for a while
but you get the point on this one number
17 and this is a technical one but I
would like to see The Return of having
multiple save files listen this is
something that a lot of games are
implementing these days and I don't know
that Nintendo will ever go back on but
typically these days when you download a
game which most people do these days I I
haven't bought a physical game in years
I don't even know when the last time is
that I bought a physical game it was was
probably breath of the wild to be honest
but most people buy digital copies and
download them and when you do download
these games they are linked to your
account not to the console and so
because of that these days a lot of
games don't let you have multiple save
files they're link to your account you
launch that game it's your one save file
and breath of the wild and tears of the
Kingdom implement this wholeheartedly
the reason why a game companies are
doing this is because it is so easy to
just generate multiple sales if you have
a family that wants to play breath of
the wild and multiple members of that
family want to play breath of the Wild
on their own and you haven't bought the
physical version then you're going to
need a separate $60 copy for every
single person that wants to play the
game but when Zelda had save files you
were able to re-experience the game
without having to erase all of your
progress and maybe be a bit more
experimental in your next playthroughs
or share it with friends or family
members who wanted to try the game but
you didn't want to wipe your game for it
it would be nice to see save files come
back stay with me here we're in the last
few number 18 I think that it could be
an entirely new setting and by that I
mean I mean that wholeheartedly I mean
it doesn't even have to be Hyrule or
maybe it does but it doesn't have to be
a game that is about link saving Zelda
from the clutches of whoever anymore it
could be a gudo adventure with an
entirely different set of characters
from the ground up maybe they don't mess
with the balance of Link Zelda and
Ganondorf maybe this isn't about the
Triforce which you know it hasn't been
about the Triforce in 10 years anyway
maybe we need an entire new set of
characters for a Mainline game and I
know what you're thinking at that point
what is keeping it a Legend of Zelda
game well let me raise the question to
you what is keeping it a Legend of Zelda
game these days there's no Triforce
there are no pieces of heart the things
that we do recognize from older Zelda
games are all different like the master
sword for instance and everything is
weirdly just like a reference and not
actually can into the game we simply
have Link and Zelda that connect it to
the other Zelda games they've been
thinking outside the box it's something
I could see happening in the next Zelda
game and it's something that I think
would only have a little bit of
complaint at first but once we all knew
and understood that it was going to be a
completely new story with completely new
characters that is somehow otherwise
connected to the Legend of Zelda maybe
it's just simply in the same universe I
think everybody would accept it and
everybody would love it given that the
narrative and gameplay are good of
course number 19
listen this one's going to sound crazy
but keep thinking about it we need more
mounts for link think about it in breath
of the wild and tears of the Kingdom you
could already go and get multiple horses
but you know what horses have in common
they're all horses the slowest one and
the fastest one are both still horses
what if link could have a flying Mount
like a loft Wing maybe it could fly but
it wasn't as fast on the ground making
it more convenient for him to switch
from a horse to his Loft wing and what
if he had underwater mounts as well what
if he could ride one of those giant
seahorses like the ones that we saw in
skyd sword or be tugged by a manay or a
I don't know a baby jabu jabu and you
could further this idea with gear for
your mounts that would actually enhance
their speed or stamina and and customize
their colorations and patterns and
whatever I think that would be a huge W
for everybody before we get to number 20
which is going to be my last point that
I'll talk about I'm going to give an
honorable mention I think that we need
to rework the art style from the ground
up I think that Zelda has spent a long
time being very cartoony ever since the
prevalence of super cartoony Graphics in
like the wind waker which if you'll
recall had such a bad backlash over its
graphical style that in Twilight
Princess which was going to be Wind
Waker 2 as according to the files of the
game they completely overhauled it and
made it the most realistic looking Zelda
game and people really liked it it was
very popular it was rated te and I get
that Nintendo is not necessarily trying
to not Market to kids anymore but they
need to remember that a huge huge huge
portion of their fans are my age or
older that is to say within the 20 to 40
age Zone we don't mind realistic looking
Graphics in fact we probably would enjoy
it quite a bit but here's the other
thing about that having realistic
Graphics in a video game requires better
Hardware to be honest which is kind of
why they decided to go with the
graphical style that they did for breath
of the wild and tears of the Kingdom
that's the only way to pull off those
vast fields of grass but hey depending
on whether or not you believe it
apparently we might be getting the
switch success with this year so let's
see what that's all about right I swear
if it's just like here's the switch OLED
part two a little bit better of a screen
and a little bit better speakers I I'm
going to I think I'm going to RI it but
anyway the last thing that I think would
be a w across the board that would make
the Legend of Zelda better than ever
number 20 we need an actual crafting
system listen cooking in the era of the
wild feels really good but I think we
could enhance cooking I think we could
bring crafting as a whole to crafting
gear repairing your armor crafting
weapons imagine that cooking returns but
it's not just five ingredients that go
into whatever dish you're trying to make
not all ingredients are created equal
right why should a whole ass turkey take
up the same ingredient slot as
salt what if we had two protein sections
and two or three like filler sections
and then like two or three uh garnishes
Each of which we could fill or not fill
that would enhance multiple kinds of
status effects for link upon consumption
giving us a system like this would
enable us to get as complex with it as
we wanted or as simple with it as we
wanted which is very important and
Telltale good game design and like I was
mentioning there are so many materials
to pick up in the worlds of breath of
the wild and tears of the king Kingdom
why can we not craft stuff with this we
can already Slaughter enemies by the
dozens and break their horns off and
stick them on weapons and stab other
enemies with them why not take their
bones and craft armor or use it as
material to repair our armor between
fusion and cooking as of tear of the
Kingdom the elements are there for a
really really wellth thought out and
intuitive and immersive crafting system
I think they just need to go that extra
step and Implement them all and there
you have it my compl list of 20 things
that Nintendo should Implement to fix
the Legend of Zelda once and for all for
everybody across the board let me remind
you that Nintendo does listen to people
specifically YouTubers you know how much
influence the zonai had in the story of
breath of the wild bayota you know how
much they had in tears of the
Kingdom actually just everything was zai
I guarantee you that was probably
because of all the chatter we had about
the zone I on YouTube so if you want
anything in this video implemented in
the next Zelda game give it a like
subscribe to the channel comment below
with what you want to see more
interaction on this video we'll get it
spread around more so let's see what we
can do and at the very least it'll get
it spread around to other Zelda fans
just like you and me who will begin this
conversation a new and who knows maybe
we could make some of this stuff happen
or hit me up on Instagram and let me
know over
[Music]
there
n